meet the tick tock doctors i'll chat to
the medics taking to social media to
dispel myths
about the covid vaccine and in addition
to that let's do
business the mayor of london sadiq khan
on why he's calling for more financial
support for firms until all coveted
restrictions
are dropped you'll join us at 9 20.
it's wednesday the 16th of june
a jab for a job it's understood covered
vaccinations will be made compulsory for
care home staff
who work with elderly people nhs workers
may also have to fall in line
a failure to weather the storm
scientists say the uk is less prepared
to deal with climate change
than it was five years ago there needs
to be much more action from government
they need they're the ones that need to
put the money in they're the ones need
to put infrastructure in they're the
ones with the regulations and laws to
force change
israel launches airstrikes in gaza the
military says it's in retaliation
for incendiary balloons fired from the
territory
a presidential summit bart will joe
biden's meeting with vladimir putin
follow convention
in geneva the final countdown
china prepares to launch its first
manned space mission in five years
and some places will be cloudy cool and
murky today with patchy rain but for the
vast majority
sunny and warm again hot and humid in
the south and east and thunderstorms
likely into tonight i'll have the
details for you later
[Music]
morning everybody if you work in a care
home looking after elderly or vulnerable
people
then you'll have to have a coronavirus
vaccination ministers want to make the
jabs mandatory and has said
to want to extend the move to cover all
nhs
staff let's bring in our political
correspondent tomorrow cohen who is
standing by for us this morning hello to
you um
tomorrow so tell us more about what the
government is hoping to achieve here
morning kay good morning we understand
that later this week they'll announce
that
all staff working in care homes for the
elderly will have to have a coronavirus
vaccine it's going to be within the next
16 weeks or they face
losing their job or being redeployed
away from front-line duties
the government has said all along that
they believe vaccines are the way
out of this pandemic and we understand
that they'll say that
thousands of lives could be saved with
this policy
now in terms of uptake at the moment the
nhs
england figures show that over 80
percent of care home staff have had
their first vaccine
almost 70 have had their second but the
concern
is that this is not uniform in some
local areas the uptake is far
far lower and we know the health
secretary has said earlier this year
that some care home chains
want uh this to be compulsory the
concern is of course and
why some trade unions representing the
sector
oppose it is because they fear that it
will exacerbate already
acute staff shortages in the social care
sector
which are also a real problem and as far
as this trade deal is concerned with
australia what's it looking like
well boris johnson was very pleased to
announce it yesterday holding some
vegemite um
in the downing street garden with the
australian prime minister
scott morrison and it has to be said
although this is the first post-brexit
trade deal to be negotiated from scratch
and the government will be very pleased
with that there are some concerns about
farming
and whether the farming sector is going
to be
have farmers forced out due to cheaper
imports of meat that
comes to a lower welfare standard and
that's what they've been
saying all along uh liz trust and the
government say
that they've put protections in that
deal so for the first 10 years there
will be quotas
on how much australian meat can be
imported but the important thing is we
have not seen the text of this deal
we had an agreement and an elbow bump
yesterday
but the fine detail will not come out
until later
this year and there are questions about
whether for the small
amount that it adds to our national
income the government's own projections
suggest
only a fraction of a percent uh it is
worth that hardship
for farmers and as far as farmers are
concerned i mean looking at the figures
um they are not at all happy suggesting
this is um
showcase rather than substance
that's right yes the farmers have
expressed concerns all along that
some of them will be forced to the wall
i mean what michael gove told us
yesterday
is that he didn't expect this to be a
huge the uk to be a huge export market
for australia because of course it is 9
000 miles away
and their biggest export markets for
produce will probably
remain in asia but farmers remain
concerned about the whole post-brexit
landscape they're going to see their
subsidies phased out over the next few
years it's not clear what support
they'll get for government
there and although government ministers
including liz trust have said well they
can find new opportunities
to export abroad it's still unclear
what the terms of that will be but the
government say that this trade deal is
going to be a win for particular
sectors what they call iconic british
brands whether that's
chocolates or cars or whiskey and they
say
that british consumers will be able to
enjoy australian products like
australian wines
at a cheaper price than they they do at
the moment because all of those
taxes and tariffs will be eliminated
okay tomorrow for now thanks very much
indeed quick look at
uh what's happening as far as the
coronavirus figures are concerned
for the uk today the latest data shows
there were 7 673 new coronavirus cases
reported
in the last 24-hour period and 10 death
that means that the
total number of people who died within
28 days of a positive test now stands
at 127 917.
another 132 627 people have received
their first vaccinations and 235
928 people have received their second
that now means 30.2 million people have
now received both doses
of a vaccine lots to talk to with the
international trade secretary
liz trustee is with us now hi good
morning good morning thanks for joining
us this morning
um let's start with that trade deal
should we um
those who are being critical say it's
more showcase and substance
well i completely disagree with this
this is the first uk trade deal that
we've struck
from scratch since brexit it's not just
important in itself it's got
huge opportunities with australia
whether it's about the under 35s being
able to go there
for three years without any farm work
requirement whether it's about
tariffs reduced on all british goods
from whiskey to cars
but what's more it's also about access
to the wider pacific market
so we want to sign up to the
trans-pacific partnership
a market of 11 countries 500 million
people
and doing this australia deal is a key
part of that as well
of course that's where the growing
demand is sure but that's all the kind
of products and services
that's why people are saying that's why
it's a showcase because actually worth
0.1 percent of
increase in gdp about 1.20 per household
per year
well that's a static analysis but what
that analysis doesn't take into account
is that those economies are growing and
they're growing fast
so we're expecting trade with australia
to increase by 30
by 2030 and with a wider trans-pacific
area
we're expecting it to increase by 65 so
what i'm doing
is striking these trade deals that are
going to put the uk in a very strong
position
you know in 2030 and 2040 and 2050
because our businesses whether it's
financial services or technology
or farmers or
whiskey they will have a bigger market
to sell into
and the british will have better access
than other countries so this deal for
example with australia
we have now got more access for brits to
go and live and work
in australia than the americans have or
the japanese have so we've got a real
strategic advantage okay at the expense
of our farmers some might say
a huge increase in meat imports into the
united kingdom 25 times
what it is at the moment is what the cap
is likely to be
emily thornbury the shadow trade
secretary as you know saying
send our farmers to the wall and the
national farmers union representative
chairman in fact uh minnett batters
saying uh we're really going to have to
look at this very carefully it's just
not good for our farmers
well what we are doing is we're making
sure there's a transition period for
farmers of 15 years
so we're going to give australia the
same access
that the eu have to our market in 15
years time
the eu already has quota free access
to the uk so they already sell us 230
000 tons
of beef per year what this deal is
talking about is next year
it'll be 35 000 tons so we we
import far more beef from the eu than we
do from australia
and what we're talking about is
rectifying that in 15 years time
it's on a sliding scale there of course
isn't it it's on this guiding scale but
none of
none of the amounts on that sliding
scale are as big
as the amount we import from the eu okay
and first of all
australia mainly sell into the asia
pacific market
which has much higher prices than here
in the uk and europe
but what the deal will also enable us to
do is get more opportunities for our
farmers
in those markets like vietnam like those
other markets where there is growing
demand
for british beef and lamb so we need to
look outwards
i think we've got to stop being
defensive and look at where the
opportunities are okay how will this
trade deal complicate matters in
northern ireland
um given that currently the government
doesn't want to enforce
any checks as far as northern ireland is
concerned the eu
is reducing checks on australia goods
the eu is going to be looking at this
and saying
hang on a minute well this trade deal is
fully compatible with the northern
ireland protocol
but what the issue is in northern
ireland
is we need the eu to be pragmatic
about the checks that are undertaken and
that was always the way the protocol was
drafted
it requires compromise between the
parties
and the eu need to be reasonable and
that's what lord frost is asking for a
deal's a deal though isn't it well the
deal was clear
within the terms of the northern ireland
protocol that there had to be
a pragmatic approach and that's what we
need to see
from the eu so we might go past the 30th
of june with our negotiations in order
to try to get this deal
over the line it's already over the line
but sorted well lord frost continues to
be in discussions with the eu to sort
this situation out but i would urge the
eu
to be responsible and be pragmatic
to sort this issue out um let me talk
about vaccines if i may
mandatory vaccination for care home
staff is that the case
well we are currently consulting on this
issue
but what we do know is that it's
incredibly important
that staffing care homes are vaccinated
we've got a hugely vulnerable population
in our care homes and making sure
that staff are vaccinated is a priority
and everybody
who has the opportunity for a vaccine
should take up that opportunity because
it's helped
protect all of us and keep all of us
safe okay exactly they don't have one
two i i i'm not going to comment
because we haven't we haven't got the
well we haven't responded to the
consultation it'd be responding wrong of
me
to prejudge that consultation but it's
clearly if you had a parent who was in a
care home
i would want to make sure i would want
the staff to be vaccinated
of course i would because i would want
my parents to be protected
what about nhs staff well i think that
everybody who has the opportunity to
have a vaccine
should have that vaccine and that's what
we want to make sure is that all adults
are vaccinated and what jeopardy should
there be if you don't have that
vaccination
well these are all issues that we're
looking at as part of the consultation
we will
respond to that consultation i can't
prejudge that but you do think but i'm
very much of the view
that we need to protect everybody in
society and the vaccine is a way to do
that and we've seen the huge progress
we've been able to make
as a result of our very strong record in
vaccination
just reading jacob reese mogg this
morning i'm sure you've been reading
what he's had to say as well it was
actually on his podcast or more cast i
think he calls it very clever
um and it's been picked up by a lot of
the newspapers this morning
saying that we can't run a society to
stop hospitals uh
becoming full isn't that exactly what we
are doing at the moment
what we're doing is we are taking a
pragmatic approach
the key is making sure that everybody
gets vaccinated
by the 19th of july we'll have all
over 40s vaccinated so that we are
protected
as a society that's what we need to do
in order to be able to
fully open up the economy what do we
think about
jacob rees-mogg has said i mean he's
completely gone off the reservation
well i haven't actually read his uh read
his blog
read his blog this morning but i let me
tell you he says
um lockdown cannot drag on just to
prevent people seeing a doctor
and that we can't run a society to stop
hospitals being
uh being full well i agree with him that
lockdown shouldn't drag on we want to
bring an end to it we've already
taken a number of steps to open up parts
of the economy
things are freer than they were a few
months ago
but i think we need to hold our nerve to
make sure
that we keep levels of the virus down
and the way to do that is through
vaccination yeah but does he not
understand that he's literally the
government's policy
is uh to have lockdown or easing of
lockdown but still
restrictions in place at the moment in
order to stop our hospitals being
fulfilled i mean it's fundamentally the
point isn't it
well the whole point is fundamentally to
protect people
and to stop people uh suffering
severe covet and dying and that is why
we're doing this we're protecting lives
that is the ultimate aim do you accept
that he's misspoken then
well i i don't know i come you just you
just read it out to me and
uh papers no i mean it's no secret well
jacob
jacob jacob has his you know his views
and that's
those are his views but what i'm telling
you is the what the reason we are doing
this the reason we are taking these
measures
is to protect lives and that's what's
important but the more serious point is
that it's
the discontent with with an extension to
lockdown
is now reaching the front bench he's the
leader of the house
when you go out and about in the uk
and talk to people about their
experiences on lockdown what they want
to see
there is huge support for the prime
minister's approach
of being cautious and making sure
that we do have people vaccinated before
we fully open up the economy we don't
want to be in a position
where we have to go backwards because
we've seen a spike
and that is why the vaccination program
is so vitally important and
there's huge public support for that
have you had both your jobs
i haven't i've got i've got one due on
saturday okay so i will be
i will be double backs then yeah did you
have oxford i did
yes no actually not at all i had to do
it i had to do a media around the next
morning so i couldn't i couldn't be
poorly
two days i was so poorly but having said
that i'm 100 invincible now i've had
both jobs and yours is this weekend
it is good thank you very much thank you
yes thanks a lot coming up on the
program
for you this morning at a quarter to
eight we'll talk to campaigners and
those with relatives and care homes
as mps call for urgent action to reform
the care system
how old should we be to get married if
you're a teenager
in love the former home secretary stated
javid wants the minimum legal age to be
raised to
18. we'll ask him ah five past eight
[Music]
then at uh 20 past we'll speak to the
former formula one world champion nico
rosberg
about why he's pumped up about dumping
petrol
and now leading a global environmental
festival
but first the latest inflation figures
from the office for national statistics
have just been released they show the
rate of inflation rose to 2.1 percent in
may up from
1.5 in april our business correspondent
paul kelso standing by for us hi paul
um analyze this for us if you would
please good morning
yeah good morning okay yes uh as you say
the
uh inflation rate has increased to 2.1
up from one and a half percent in april
which in itself
was up uh more than 100 percent on the
previous month this is all year on year
figures so we should be comparing them
in our minds
to where prices were a year ago when we
of course we were
emerging from the first lockdown and
what they tell us
is that the recovery in the economy is
well underway in fact the economy is in
some sense is roaring back
perhaps a little too fast for some
tastes
which is why prices are rising the main
drivers of these price increases
uh cake clothing and shoes cart motor
fuel
cost of petrol and diesel at the pump a
great deal more than a year ago because
the oil price has risen substantially
and recreational goods so we're going
out and spending money
both outside the home and inside food
and drink
has driven a lot of this uh for that
purchased outside the home of course
remember a year ago
that was a very limited choice these
figures for may so we were still locked
down a year ago
now of course people are out and about
one significance perhaps of this number
today 2.1 percent it's above
the bank of england's target rate for
inflation of 2 percent
and we've seen concern not just in the
uk but around
the world in global economies about uh
increasing
inflation in the us it's been they've
been spooked a little we know that
there's supply problems so while there's
great demand from consumers like us
uh manufacturers are struggling to get
goods to us will the bank of england act
and
address the interest rate the wide
expectation is
not now but perhaps sooner
than expected okay paul thank you
also making the news for you this
morning israel says it's launched
airstrikes in the gaza strip in
retaliation for incendiary balloons
fired from the territory it's the first
major clash since 11 days of fighting
between the two sides
ended late last month
21 and 22 year olds are being asked to
book their coronavirus vaccinations
the nhs says it will send out nearly a
million texts today asking them to come
forward
18 to 20 year olds are expected to be
invited before the end of the week
new research suggests the number of
people taking a coronavirus vaccine
could increase if more treatment
for fear of needles was available a
study by the university of oxford claims
around a quarter of adults in the uk are
scared
of injections me included
scotland yard has promised to review
allegations that gelane maxwell
was involved in trafficking grooming and
abusing women and girls in the uk
the former girlfriend of convicted sex
offender jeffrey epstein
is in custody in the united states
accused of recruiting teenage girls for
him to sexually abuse
the uk is even less prepared to deal
with climate change conditions hitting
the country now than it was
five years ago that's according to the
government's own climate change experts
they say new build homes are poorly
designed and can't cope
with the impact of rising temperatures
here's our climate change correspondent
lisa holland
with rock from local quarries aberdeen
is known as the granite city
distinctive architecture but old granite
buildings
are notoriously difficult to keep warm
this is the cavity
and this cavity is ventilated to under
the floor and this is vital in order to
keep the inner wall
here dry engineer david mcgrath is
developing ways to make
homes more energy efficient and is
insulating his son's granite house in
aberdeen
he believes not enough is being done to
help people retrofit their homes
for all properties like this is vitally
important
in on two fronts one we have to
do some mitigation for climate change
but actually a lot of the
illnesses that are formed are because of
the very construction of these
properties
it's not just buildings that are poorly
insulated or overheat
which pose a risk to our health and
welfare
people nature and infrastructure are all
threatened by climate change
there needs to be much more action from
government they need they're the ones
that need to put the money in they're
the ones need to put infrastructure in
they're the ones with the regulations
and laws to force change
i mean people will will change when they
when they're told to do so and we will
take individual action but we need
support in that
buffeted by extreme weather aberdeen is
a city which sees itself as on the front
line of climate change
in a stark warning the climate change
committee which advises the uk
government how to get to net zero
says the country is unprepared for what
lies ahead
i think the government's response has
been inadequate we've seen the the
the science of climate change has
improved uh progressively over time
we've become more and more aware of the
risks that we face and yet we haven't
seen
a commensurate response from the
government to those risks and it's time
for the government to now act on that
the climate change committee says
ambition needs to be matched with
adaptation
and insists we're now in a critical
period for dealing with the impact of
climate change in the uk
lisa holland sky news aberdeen
[Applause]
and for similar news and stories from
the people trying to stop
climate change you can watch the daily
climate show on sky news
you can join sam washington uh 6 30
and 9 30 this evening usually anna jones
of course is
on holiday at the moment or if you're on
the go you can download and listen to
the latest edition of our weekly climate
cast podcast available now wherever you
get your podcast
from
more headlines for you this morning now
elderly campaign groups say the number
of pensioners in poverty
has exceeded two million with black and
asian
older people more at risk of struggling
financially
age uk is calling on all older people to
check their eligibility for pensioner
credit
over fears they'll miss out
we're looking at how people compare with
the rest of the population
and sometimes some groups get left
behind a bit
but we do know that one of the reasons
why people are living
in poverty unnecessarily is because they
aren't claiming any benefit entitlements
that they should be
so people are missing out and
particularly on pension credit there's
nearly a million
pensioner households who should be
receiving the benefit pension credit
it's claimed more than half of firms
outside the biggest 350 companies still
have no female bosses
the group women on boards uk says less
than half of these firms meet the uk's
goal of women occupying a
third of executive roles
today marks the fifth anniversary of the
death of the labour mp joe cox
in a statement her family said they were
optimistic about a future where people
recognize
we have things in common
china's confirmed it will launch its
first manned space mission in five years
tomorrow morning
three astronauts are due to spend
several months on border space station
and will also carry out
a space walk
more than four billion dollars has been
wiped off the coca-cola share price
after this gesture by cristiano
ronaldo the footballer removed two coke
bottles from the desk during his euro
2020 news conference
he then toasted with a bottle of water
goodness me they need to fix that don't
they quit look at the weather for you
here's nars
good morning it's all going on today
we've got hot and humid conditions
for some we could see the highest
temperature of the year so far others
seeing cloudy skies patchy light rain
and drizzle
and then tonight thunderstorms
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning on the face of it for most
places today it's looking fine and dry
with some good spells of sunshine a warm
day
but rather hot and humid around central
southern and eastern areas
where around the south and east we're
likely to see the highest temperature of
the year so far and for some it's
looking cloudy
mainly this afternoon across southern
parts of scotland northwest england the
west of wales and down towards parts of
devon and cornwall
becoming brighter after a cloudy and
damp murky start around eastern parts of
ireland
northern and northern ireland too and
for the rest of ireland northern ireland
scotland
there will be brighter sunny spurs that
will feel warm but as i said hot and
humid down towards
central southern and eastern areas the
highest temperature of the year so far
likely down towards the southeast 30 to
31 degrees celsius than tonight
torrential downpours with thunderstorms
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
i was trying to remember the name for
chinese astronauts and it wouldn't come
to me i've googled it
do you know what they're called yeah
technology technology is what they're
called if they're chinese astronauts
stuart my uh director is very impressed
with that uh also coming up for you a
chance for me to bring you a story with
a very happy ending
this morning i know
a magical stormzy has been released back
into the wild after he was rescued in
suffolk he was found last month
having collapsed in the cold wet weather
the rspca says they have been able to
return him after
identifying the set that he came from
how did they know that don't they all
look the same i don't know
still to come on on the breakfast show
for you this morning joined by a former
senior us diplomat ahead of today's
face-to-face meeting
between joe biden and vladimir putin in
switzerland
how lovely that's next
[Music]
well it kind of made all the difference
really and it wasn't just the birds song
it was the landscapes then
they inhabited um and um i suppose
these events smash and bash their way
into your life without permission and
i found birdsong the perfect inbuilt
coping mechanism for me it it affects
you and
your nature does stuff to you that you
don't know it's doing
and i are doing to you and i you know
had ignored
these beautiful sounds for so long
um and and and nature i've got on with
my life i'm not a bird watcher or an
ornithologist and
it's like so much old wallpaper all
around you these these sparrows and
these robins and these black birds and
green finches
and it just by tuning in just helped
give my life perspective and take me
away from myself i suppose
i live near the pewsie vale i was up on
the downlands there
at one of the one of the lowest points
of my my life really mum had just been
diagnosed with terminal cancer and given
a very short amount of time to live and
no one prepares you for bad news in life
and lying there
listening to skylark or skylock suddenly
started singing above me and
there's some it's like a injection of
neat hope to the soul
um and um it made me realize that when
was the last time that i actually sat
and listened to the song of a bird and
and it really was the start of a journey
of of tuning in again
to everything that i had ignored for so
long we overthink life
the only point of life is is just to
live and i think the birds and the
sparrows
they show us they just get on no matter
what our problems are
you know what it taught me i suppose i'm
no longer the lead role
in my own private melodrama but just a
bit part
in nature's great epic you know this big
ecosystem around us going on
whatever's happening in our wider life
hello my name is nadja frontier
my name is ryan matthews i'm the marine
assistant
at rather a research station which is to
the west of the west
antarctic peninsula
so far i've been here for five months
and it is an absolutely wonderful
experience
my name is fatima zazile the founder of
ikisa from kuwait where we face many
environmental problems related to waste
pollution the frustration
and lack of information we are
collecting recyclables
from houses schools and businesses in
order to recycle them
[Music]
exchange if you recycle to get a treat
[Music]
hi again everybody uh sky news
understands the government wants to make
it mandatory for care home staff in
england to have a coronavirus vaccine
a consultation is also underway on
whether all nhs staff
should be forced to have the jab short
time ago the international trade
secretary liz trust told me
vaccinating care home staff is a
government priority
it's incredibly important that staffing
care homes
are vaccinated we've got a hugely
vulnerable population
in our care homes and making sure
that staff are vaccinated is a priority
and everybody
who has the opportunity for a vaccine
should take up that opportunity because
it's helped proven protect
all of us ms trust has also said that
the government's new agreement with
australia comes at a time
when trade is already growing between
the two countries she assured me the
post-brexit deal
would provide a major economic boost to
the uk
we're expecting trade with australia to
increase by 30
by 2030 and with a wider trans-pacific
area we're expecting it to increase by
65
so what i'm doing is striking these
trade deals
that are going to put the uk in a very
strong position
you know in 2030 and 2040 and 2050
because our businesses whether it's
financial services or technology
or farmers or
whiskey they will have a bigger market
to sell into
and the british will have better access
than other countries so this deal for
example with australia
we have now got more access for brits to
go and live and work
in australia than the americans have all
the japanese have so we've got a real
strategic advantage
let's bring in our political
correspondent tomorrow cohen that may
well be the case but
uh our farmer's not at all happy in the
nfu
chairperson saying we need to look at
this
yes although there are protections built
into this trade deal to account for the
concerns
of farmers that they will be flooded
with cheaper
imports of meat which are produced to a
less high welfare standard because the
farms in australia have different
standards
and are far bigger the governments say
that over
10 years there will be quotas which will
be phased out
but the farming community say this may
not stop hundreds if not more
farms going to the wall because of all
the
changes to uh the subsidies that come
with leaving the european union
and the fact that they might now be
maybe undercut by the trade deals that
the government
is now doing now liz trust rejected that
saying that farmers will be able to have
more opportunities to sell their produce
further afield
in australia and the pacific region she
also
dismissed the idea that according to the
government's own
figures which said that consumers would
benefit from this trade deal
to the tune of 34 million pounds which
sounds like rather a lot except it's
only just over one pound per household
she said that's the figure now all the
growth in trade over the next 10 years
or so
is going to come from australia and the
pacific and the government very much
hopes that this trade deal
that boris johnson sealed yesterday with
the australian prime minister
will pave the way for a much bigger one
with seven
countries in the pacific region okay for
now thank you thanks tomorrow
uh two of the most powerful world
leaders come face to face later on today
when joe biden and vladimir putin meet
in switzerland
it takes place just days after president
putin said relations between russia and
the united states were at their lowest
point where do they go from here let's
find out with the former u.s ambassador
to
ukraine and director of the eurasia
center
atlantic council and that's john herbst
hello to you
thank you for joining us mr ambassador
on the program this morning
where do you see the relationship
between the us and russia at the moment
um the relationship is exactly
unfortunately where it should be which
is a
point and it's at a low point because mr
putin has been running
wild on globally for the past seven or
eight years
um his war on ukraine his uh
intervention in syria
his intervention in elections in the
united states and across europe
including in your brexit election
he's been behaving like a rogue actor
and it's taken the united states a
couple of years but over the past five
or six
it has begun to push back hard against
moscow's provocative behavior
and the kremlin doesn't like it hence
the relationship is not in a good spot
how does president biden's approach to
president putin
differ to that of president trump
president trump had an odd and
unexplained affection
for mr putin and for russia and he he
expressed that
from time to time including during his
infamous press conference with putin in
helsinki
in 2018. but his administration despite
that pushed back
pretty strongly against the aggressive
policies of the kremlin
biden has a clear understanding of those
aggressive policies
and he and his administration also push
back
the important difference is that biden
again clearly understands the problem
and expresses that publicly as he did
during his op-ed
the op-ed he wrote for the washington
post um a few days ago
so he has been tr as we know he's been
to the g7 in cornwall he's been to nato
and now he's going to be
meeting uh president putin a very
different situation to what he's had to
do
over the last few days in that the
leaders that he's been meeting he's had
to try and mend fences between the
united states
and whichever countries leader he's
talking to a very different situation
from what you're saying
with president putin where he uh
president trump had a very good
relationship with him or a good
relationship certainly
um you're right that the meetings with
nato the meanings of the g7
and also with european union leaders
were all designed to
re-establish reassure our partners that
we are good allies
and that was a smart play to do for
going to see mr putin
because this underscores the american
strength
of globally and it makes putin's job a
little bit harder
and that's a good thing how significant
then is the meeting in geneva what do
you expect to come out of it
um if biden pursues the right um
positions which i think he will
no very little will come out of it the
most important thing is that biden has
to tell putin
stop your war in done boss in ukraine
stop interfering in american elections
stop interfering in elections across the
globe stop these ransomware attacks on
the united states
um and also do not do not kill mr
navalny
those are all difficult messages for
putin to hear
uh but biden will also say that while we
will push back hard against all these
aggressive policies of yours
we have some things we can discuss where
you may want to work with us for example
on strategic arms strategic nuclear arms
that's what i hope and expect mr biden
will say if he does
putin will obviously not be happy about
those first messages i've just described
but he may decide that yes it makes
sense to sit down with the united states
and deal
with the nuclear arms issues yeah don't
do any
yeah sorry mr ambassador i don't do any
of those things
um uh president biden will say to
president putin or else what
well you've already seen um an american
response in the past to such behavior
um principally we've levied sanctions on
the kremlin
for such behavior including as recently
as two months ago
um in connection with the war in ukraine
the united states has provided
significant military support to ukraine
as well as sanctioned the kremlin
uh but i think the other things that
biden should do
uh this is actually very important there
needs to be some american
cyber attacks on russia they did not
need to be spoken of publicly
but we need to demonstrate to mr putin
that we have a stronger cyber capability
than russia
and that they will pay dearly if they
continue such attacks on the united
states
um one assumes that potentially that
might be happening already if they're
not
spoken about publicly mr ambassador but
nevertheless let me ask you very briefly
before
i let you go the chair of the uk defense
select committee told me last week that
the west is facing
a new cold war with russia would you
agree with that assessment
well um i would say we've been in a cold
war for many years
it took the west and the united states
too some time to understand that
but putin has been pursuing a policy
directly contrary to american
and nato interests including britain and
britain's interests
since at least 2007 when it launched a
cyberware
attack on estonia and then 2008 when it
invaded georgia and then 2014 when it
seized crimea
and began its war in dunbas in ukraine
not to mention all the electoral
interference we've talked about
going back the last seven or eight years
so the united states and the west again
took him a little bit of time to realize
this
but once they did they began to push
back and that's when moscow began to
talk about a cold war
but it's a cold war that the kremlin
launched let's understand that
and we're merely protecting ourselves mr
ambassador thank you so much for staying
up into the early hours in washington to
speak to us we do appreciate it thanks a
lot
my pleasure thank you thank you
uh coming up why there are calls for the
adult care system to be
overhauled we'll be talking about that
in just
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
they have breached the road there is a
lot of
gas being fired all around us
[Music]
it is an absolute carnival kind of
atmosphere out here for prime minister
modi's decisive
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Applause]
the roads have been inundated the only
way out
is to get people by boat
what is shared that over 200 people
might have died because of these
landslides
this on any given day would have been
bustling with people but today
it's absolutely deserted
is one of the most sensitive areas of of
northeast delhi where there's been
clashes i'm never lazarus and i'm skies
reporter based in delhi
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
done
did you know symptoms of hay fever can
develop at any stage of life
not just in childhood the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
purifiers
most of southern scotland the north and
west of england and the west of wales
will be rather cloudy cool and murky
this afternoon with light rain and
drizzle
elsewhere will be fine warm and sunny
but hot and humid
for central southern and eastern england
where thunderstorms are likely into
tonight
so grass pollen is now in peak season
fungal spores are at a medium risk and
there's lots of weed pollen about too
pollen levels will be high or very high
for england today and
high for much of wales whereas northern
ireland will be moderate and scotland
will be low once again
the pollen reports sponsored by philips
connected air purifiers
calls this morning for urgent reform of
the care system
in england the house of commons public
accounts committee says there needs to
be
proper funding and warns the pandemic
has had what it calls a devastating
impact on the on the service
uh fraser mortal reports
enjoying the sunshine and some
traditional seaside fun
the residents have sent cecilia's in
scarborough
here as in hundreds of other care homes
lives have been lost
during the pandemic taking a toll on the
residents their families
and the staff those who work in the care
sector
say today's report by the public
accounts committee doesn't tell them
anything new they know action is needed
and with many homes now operating at
only 80
capacity they need it to happen soon i'd
like the government to be bold and
committed and to actually give us a date
when it's
going to start and finish the reforms
really if they can't do that then i
suggest
someone else comes in and actually does
it because we've heard promises broken
promises
over more than two decades and enough is
enough it's about time someone stood up
and said
this is when it's happening the report
concludes that care is not properly
funded
lacks transparency and urgently needs
reform
we've said really that the government
has failed on social care
and not just the devastation that it
faced during covid
but it has a track record that we have
highlighted a number of times
not delivering on many aspects of
supporting people in care homes and
getting care at home
residents like david who's been at
census elias for seven years greatly
appreciate the work of their carers
they're worth the waiting gold they come
here at seven o'clock in the morning
ready for work
and we don't get them tonight at night
and leave it out that's a long shift you
know
and they're on the feet imagine the
margins they're walking around all the
time
you know just phenomenal the staff
themselves
love their jobs but often feel
undervalued
you can't teach someone to care they
either have care or they don't have care
and to be able to look after people
especially with the needs that our our
residents have
that it takes some doing today's report
calls for this government to finally
deliver the reforms that have long been
promised
starting with an outline by next month
on how much support is needed
to cope with the immediate crisis caused
by kovid 19.
fraser moored sky news scarborough
let's talk about this in more detail
gene adamson
is a bereaved family member
last year sadly lost her father to
covert 19 whilst in
a care home um hi gene it's lovely to
see you this morning thanks for joining
us
um tell us what happened to your dad
cleo i think his name was wasn't it
yes my father was um was in a care home
um he was admitted there after having
had a
stroke um and was left quite debilitated
and he spent uh 18 months in the care
home
altogether before he contracted covid
um and unfortunately passed away um
during the the first wave of the
pandemic
um april last year what were your
favorite memories of him do you have
some when you think about him that bring
a smile to your face
yes i do my dad was a trooper
and and he was a family man as well uh
when he went into the care home
um they had that the doctors had given
him
three to six months to live um
because he also had a brain tumor um and
and they've given him that time to live
and
the doctor used to go in each week
because he was on end of life care and
say
um okay you know do we need to review
anything here and and in the end
the doctor said well why is this man on
end of life care you know
he's uh he's hearty and strong and
you know he he loved to sing he would
sit up and sing in bed every day
um you know he was such a peaceful and
contented soul
um anyway in the end they took him off
the end of life care and
and and he then went on to live another
year
before he contracted covet in the home
um
and died um but um my dad i fondly
remember my dad as a
uh he's a he was a windrush pioneer
and uh you know he he loved to wear his
trilby hats
and he would serenade his grandchildren
with
you know old-time west indian uh songs
and um yes he was a uh a very
a very strong and uh robust man
robust character yeah but sadly
um he did succumb to kovid and you
weren't
able to visit him were you um towards
the end of his life
in in the care home what impact did that
have on you and the family
that was very very hard on us you know
because we we we were
you know we we couldn't see him um and
unfortunately because of the effects of
stroke
he was unable to communicate with us so
we we weren't even able to
you know just speak to him um
you know on the phone or or using an
ipad
so it was very hard um
you know being able to communicate with
him and
at any level um but i was i suppose we
we were fortunate in one sense because
he was on the ground floor of the care
home uh we were able to go and uh
stand by outside his window and at least
we could talk to him
through the window and he could hear our
voice you know um
and he would sometimes respond to that
um but it was a very difficult time and
wasn't able to
say goodbye to him uh before he died
that was particularly sad i'm sure gene
i'm sure what more do you think
politicians in westminster i mean this
report is coming out soon what more do
you think politicians in westminster
should be doing to help
people like your family
the politicians
need to stop the infighting
and the uh the bickering and the
um uh self-serving
tactics that they use uh politicians
need to
to realize that
this is a tragedy a national tragedy
on a massive scale unprecedented
in our times and it needs to be treated
with the
relevant the appropriate um uh
uh degree of urgency
and we need to have a public inquiry
as soon as possible so that we can
understand what happened what went wrong
um why why why things went wrong
and make recommendations and learn
lessons
going forward so that we don't have
a repeat of of this uh
the the the massive scale of of of um
uh um tragedy um
again you know the massive loss of life
again i mean we've had already
you know we've lost over what's 127 000
uh people have lost their lives covered
um
we're now possibly going onto a third
wave
you know we have the delta variants now
which is um
you know rising exponentially
how many more people need to die
before the government will actually
to take affirmative action get the
inquiry going
and so that we can learn lessons and
avoid further loss of life okay
ended gene i'm sure your dad cleo would
have been very very proud of you thank
you so much for taking the time to join
us this morning thank you
thank you thanks thank you for chatting
um to the government minister this
morning about uh care homes
and the fact that staff do they need to
have compulsory two jobs in order
to work in care homes in future and also
uh do we
think that nhs workers should compulsory
have two
jobs we'll be talking about that see
what she had to say at the top of the
next hour
but before that something completely
different um before the weather
the name might suggest different but
scientists say like us
killer whales make friends
there they are this is the footage from
a team at the university of exeter and
the center for whale research which they
say
proves their theory they believe the
whales spend more time interacting with
specific other individuals
within their pod and it appears they are
picky creatures they apparently like
spending time with wales of a similar
sex
and age to themselves
what happens what happens when you fall
out with a killer whale though i don't
know
let's find out what's happening in wales
now
here's nas
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning all going on today we've
got fine conditions for most places but
not everywhere there's cloudy skies
likely for this afternoon across
southern scotland north west england the
western wales down towards the southwest
later
as that band of cloud patchy light rain
also
drizzle also clears from eastern parts
of ireland to northern ireland the rest
of ireland northern ireland scotland
fine and warm but scattered showers
around
the windy north and west hot and humid
for many southern and eastern areas
where we're likely to see the highest
temperature of the year so far
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
coming up in the next hour for you as i
said we've been talking to the
government minister liz trust following
reports
that coronavirus vaccines are to be made
mandatory for staffing care homes
uh we'll hear what she said about that
in just a few moments time here on the
breakfast show
on skype
[Music]
[Applause]
hello or like we say in my language is
lay
i am tony the founder and the ceo of the
new world in africa this picture changed
my whole career
and my whole life our mission is simple
is to bring back power to africa
and our need is to turn the dark
continent that i saw in 2008
into a brighter and prosperous one by
[Applause]
2040.
[Music]
now that music for you
[Music]
it's all to do with tick-tock doctors
i'm going to be chatting to the medics
taking to social media to dispel myths
about the kovid
vaccines and let's do business
the mayor of london city khan and why
he's calling for more financial support
for firms
until all kobe restrictions are dropped
and he's joining us
at 9 20 this morning it's wednesday the
16th
of june a job for a job with
understood covered vaccinations will be
made compulsory for care home staff who
work with elderly people
i would want the staff to be vaccinated
of course i would
because i would want my parents to be
protected
a failure to weather the storm
scientists say the uk
is less prepared to deal with climate
change than it was
five years ago there needs to be much
more action from government they need
they're the ones that need to put the
money in
they're the ones need to put
infrastructure in they're the ones with
the regulations and laws to force change
israel launches airstrikes in gaza the
military says it's in retaliation for
incendiary balloons fired from the
territory
presidential summit but will joe biden's
meeting with vladimir putin follow
convention
in geneva the final countdown china
prepares to launch its first manned
space mission in
five years and it's looking fine and dry
for most places cloudy for some though
with
damp conditions hot and humid for others
where we could see the highest
temperature of the year so far
before thunderstorms tonight i'll have
the details later
[Music]
hello everyone now if you work in a care
home looking after elderly all
vulnerable people then
you'll have to have a coronavirus
vaccination ministers want to make the
jobs mandatory apparently
and are said to want to extend the move
to cover all
of the nhs staff in the last hour i
asked the international trade secretary
list trust to confirm
whether it was going to happen everybody
who has the opportunity for a vaccine
should take up that opportunity because
it's helped proven protect all of us
and keep all of us safe okay exactly
they don't have one
two i i'm not gonna comment because we
haven't
we haven't got the well we haven't
responded to the consultation it'd be
responding wrong of me
to prejudge that consultation but it's
clearly if you had a parent who was in a
care home
i would want to make sure i would want
the staff to be vaccinated
of course i would because i would want
my parent to be protected
well also this morning the cabinet
minister jacob rees-mogg and father of
the house has suggested
the lockdown can't continue just to
protect the nhs
government policy is that the lockdown
is needed to protect the nhs
but speaking on his podcast jacob
rees-mogg said that the nhs is there to
serve the british people
not the british people there to serve
the nhs
i put that to this trust i agree with
him
that lockdown shouldn't drag on we want
to bring an end to it we've already
taken a number of steps to open up parts
of the economy
things are freer than they were a few
months ago
but i think we need to hold our nerve to
make sure
that we keep levels of the virus down
and the way to do that is through
vaccination
let's bring in our political
correspondent to marico and let's start
with jacob reese monk there should we i
mean
they have been trying to keep a lid on
him haven't they for quite a while the
conservatives but he's popped up again
morning k yes we haven't heard um much
from jacob rees-mogg
since some comments he made about the
grenfell tower at fire
well over a year ago he seems to have
given it an interview
to the conservative home website and
spoken on a podcast
saying that he doesn't think the
lockdown can last
forever just to stop hospitals being
full which is of course the entire
reason
for the lockdown to prevent the nhs
being overwhelmed which is why the
government keep talking about whether
we can have a rise in cases which does
not lead
to hospitalizations and deaths and the
reason that they brought in
this four week to delay to what we call
freedom day in
england is because those
hospitalizations were from a low base
starting to tick up in a concerning way
so
i'm sure the government won't be
thrilled to hear jacob rees-mogg
publicly
dissenting from that he does reflect
though strand of opinion in the
conservative
party there will be a vote in parliament
this afternoon on extending
those restrictions in england the
government are going to comfortably win
that because labour are supporting them
but we'll see how many tory mps come out
with similar sentiments
to jacob rees-mogg later on today saying
that they feel that perhaps
this will never end if we have
restrictions into the wintertime or
perhaps into next year
and two jabs so you're sacked as far as
care workers and nhs staff is concerned
that's right kay we at sky news
understand that that will be announced
later this week by the government that
all staff work
in care homes for the elderly will have
to have
a coronavirus vaccine and if they don't
therefore they face
losing their job or being redeployed
away
from frontline work caring for people
the government has been consulting on
this
for a couple of months now we know
they've said that vaccination is the way
out of this pandemic
and those who are at highest risk must
be protected which is of course
vulnerable elderly people who who've
accounted for
the most part of those serious illnesses
and deaths during this pandemic now
the the care home sector have been
against this uh saying that it could
exacerbate what are already acute
staffing shortages and it's better to
just try and reassure people
now we know from official figures that
over 80 percent
of care home staff have had their first
job
the concern though is that that masks
the fact that in some local authority
areas it's
far far lower than that and the health
secretary himself
said earlier this year that some care
home bosses actually want this
to be made law it's expected to come in
in 16
weeks time okay for now thanks tamara
thank you
uh still to come on the program for you
20 past we're going to be speaking to
the former formula one world champion
nico
rosberg about why he's pumped up about
dumping fuel and now leading a global
environmental festival
after bbc bosses admitted they were
wrong not to sack martin beshear for
lying over his interview with diana
princess of wales
we'll talk to former bbc governor sir
richard air
at 8 30. and the actor stephen tomkinson
lost his dad to dementia
and is part of a campaign calling on the
government to increase
funding for research into the condition
he'll tell us his story
out of 20 tonight
at the house of commons will today
discuss plans to raise the minimum
age at which you can get married in
england and wales are present 16 and 17
year olds can marry
with permission from their parents
joined now by the conservative mp and
former chancellor and home secretary
sadie javid
hello to you thanks for joining us uh mr
javid this morning
why do you want that uh age increased
well as you said that the bill actually
is very straightforward to raise the
minimum age of marriage in england and
wales to 18.
why do i want to increase because child
marriage is child abuse i think it
really is as simple as that
there is no good reason to marry a 16
or 17 year old and it's something that
people often talk about
happens you know child marriage in
developing countries it's happening
right here in our country it's been
allowed
by the law for decades and we have to
put an end to it
there was a bill i think i'm writing
saying uh that was brought to the house
in 2018 when you were
at the home office at home secretary um
and the view then was that the
government had not seen any evidence of
any connection between forced marriage
and the marriages of people of 16 and
17.
what's changed your mind in the last
three years mr chavez well
well i would say first of all i think
that was my view uh that
i think that's really a reflection
understandably that the government
has done a lot of work especially over
the last decade
uh on both coerced and forced marriages
but i think that this is just one big
sort of area that still exists you the
ability to get married to have children
to get married that needs to be
closed off and as home secretary there's
not
much i could do about it it's the
responsibility of the justice department
but
what has changed now is that we also
have a justice secretary
that i've talked to about this that
shares my determination to end child
marriage so we're having very
constructive discussions and that's why
i'm confident that ultimately i can get
government support for this because
this is a private member's bill as you
say and private members bill
don't really get through parliament
without government support but if i can
win
that then we can change the law
something else
while you were uh at the home office um
i think i'm right in saying that you
removed the citizenship of shamima begum
she
is now saying that she's reformed that
she wants to come back
to the united kingdom have you changed
your mind on that as well
no no not at all look uh i i don't want
to talk about a
a a particular uh case of particularly
when it involves a
sensitive and intelligence information
but on on on cases of that type
um i am happy with every single decision
that i made because when you are home
secretary your primary responsibility
is to protect this country and everyone
that lives inside this country
and and that means you have to take
decisions
uh and not everyone might find them
popular but your primary
motive is to protect everyone in this
country and when you are given
overwhelming evidence
uh in a situation like this then you
follow
that advice and and most importantly my
decision was tested and went right up to
the supreme court
and the supreme court backed my decision
on all
five accounts that it was challenged
under no i understand that absolutely
uh mr javi i just wanted you know two
years on and she says that she's
reformed um it is a girl a former
british citizen who is now stateless
what should happen to us should she just
be kept in in
camps forever
well my as home secretary when i was
home secretary
and i think this goes for the current
home secretary as well
your your only motivation is to protect
the citizens
uh in britain and it's my view that
if any one of these foreign fighters or
anyone that went abroad to support a
terrorist group a terrorist organization
that was killing innocent civilians
uh that wants to come back to this uk i
think it would
most likely have a really significant
negative impact here in the uk and put
british citizens
uh under threat and that's to me is
something that will be unacceptable
so i think the primary concern should be
what should be done to protect british
citizens
and the answer to that is not to allow
individuals that represent a threat to
the country to come back and we couldn't
detain her in a british jail for example
no i think i've answered your question
i'm pretty clear on that okay let me ask
you
about when you were um former child well
you were chancellor of course previously
you've seen this trade deal with
australia what are your thoughts on that
i'm really pleased with it i think it's
a it's great to get a trade deal done
so soon uh after we've left the eu
that wasn't a sort of rollover deal from
uh our membership of the eu and
and the fact that we can get a deal so
quickly with one of our
major trading partners uh is is
excellent and i think it's going to be
good
both for us and the australians which is
the the best type of trade deal you can
get
okay are we worried at all about british
farmers
i think from what i've seen the the
detail uh on this is that with the
transition periods that have been agreed
uh i think that's a a good way to gently
uh bring in a trade deal that can
protect both the interests of farmers
but also the interests of uh consumers
in terms of
you know more choice and better prices
in the long term
so i think again i don't have all the
detail but certainly from what i've
heard is that it strikes the right
balance um
you left government before it became the
pandemic became a real issue
uh for the role of chancellor when you
look back now do you think
phew thank goodness for that
no um i don't i i think the reasons i
left government
are well known i talked about it at the
time there's nothing uh to
add to that and uh i i don't think like
that i just uh
uh i i think the the government's had
the an incredibly tough job
uh i think they've done uh their very
best overall whether it's protecting the
economy or getting us through
the worst the pandemic certainly uh the
the vaccine response
has been the best in the world and uh
you know my only
uh inclination motivation in all of this
is to try my best to
support the government through this very
very difficult time reshuffle has been
touted man
it has been touted many times over the
last few months would you answer the
call
if your prime minister wanted you in
cabinet again
no i'm not going to speculate about that
that's oh that's a yes then isn't it
it's their very last thing on the prime
minister's mind because i'm sure it's
absolutely just focused
uh on on the on the crisis that we have
been facing and getting us through that
and uh let's see what happens next
uh it's a pleasure if i can just go okay
but really
this this bill today that i'll be
presenting to parliament
that's what i'm most focused on right
now because we must bring an end to this
this is uh your child marriage is child
abuse and it's time we put a stop to it
indeed so we did talk about that
quite extensively at the start of this
interview it's a pleasure to see you
looking so well thank you for joining us
mr james thank you thank you very much
thanks thank you two of the most
powerful world leaders come face to face
later on today when joe biden and
vladimir putin meet in switzerland
takes place just days after president
putin said relations between russia
and the united states were at the lowest
point
well our u.s correspondent mark stone
joining us now from
geneva beautiful behind you there mark
avery good morning what is the best they
can hope for from this meeting
good morning
hello kay yes a very very hot beautiful
day here in
a deserted geneva they have literally
cleared the streets
and cleared the lake as well as these
two
world leaders meet here for the first
time
as with um joe biden as us president for
a summit that i think
is high stakes but low on expectation i
don't think and indeed
diplomats on both sides are playing down
any expectations
of some sort of a a light bulb moment
between the two leaders this is
the beginning of trying to reset
relations they're not even using the
word reset they think that would come
later this is just trying to
to get the two leaders together to get
them talking
they talk about this phrase strategic
dialogue
and i think that is going to be key it's
technical but but i think it goes to the
heart of the relationship between
these two countries because at the
moment that strategic dialogue is at an
all-time low there is no
discussion there is no mechanism to cool
tensions between the two countries no
mechanism
to dial down um the potential of a
military conflict and i think that
uh will be at the heart of their
discussions uh today
at some a villa inside the um uh this uh
park on the on the lakes of on the banks
of
of lake geneva they will meet at lunch
time they will meet uh one-on-one
um initially with with just their um one
plus one i should say with just
the u.s secretary of state and the the
russian foreign minister
at their sides and later on there will
be uh other aides on both sides will
join them and then a press conference at
around about 6 p.m we thought at one
stage it would be a joint press
conference
uh diplomats on both sides thought that
would be just too risky and so we'll
hear
first i think from mr putin and then
later from mr biden so yeah high stakes
low on expectation though
of any big outcomes okay for now thank
you thanks a lot mark
also making the news for you this
morning
israel says it's launched airstrikes and
the gaza strip in retaliation for
incendiary balloons fired from the
territory
it's the first major clash since 11 days
of fighting between the two sides
ended late last month china's confirmed
it will launch its first manned space
span
i'm going to go have another go at that
first manned space
mission a lot of alliteration for an
anxious anchor in five years
tomorrow morning three astronauts or
technauts as they call them
are due to spend several months on board
a space station
and will also carry out a space walk
this is unbelievable more than four
billion dollars has been wiped
off the coca-cola share price because of
that move
by cristiano ronaldo the footballer
removed two coke bottles from the death
during the euro 2020 news conference
he then toasted with a bottle of water
oh marketing guys are tearing their hair
out this morning
the latest inflation figures from the
office for national statistics have been
released they show the rate of inflation
rose to 2.1 percent in may
up from 1.5 in april we'll be talking
about that with
our business correspondent paul kelso in
just a few moments time
before that though the uk is even less
prepared to deal with climate change
conditions hitting the country now
than it was five years ago apparently
that's according to the government's
own climate change experts they say new
built homes are poorly designed and
can't cope
with the impact of rising temperatures
here's our climate change correspondent
lisa holland
with rock from local quarries aberdeen
is known as the granite city
distinctive architecture but old granite
buildings are notoriously difficult to
keep warm
this is the cavity and this cavity is
ventilated to
under the floor and this is vital in
order to keep the inner wall
here dry engineer david mcgrath is
developing ways to make homes more
energy efficient
and is insulating his son's granite
house in aberdeen
he believes not enough is being done to
help people retrofit their homes
for all properties like this is vitally
important
in on two fronts one we have to do some
mitigation
for climate change but actually a lot of
the
illnesses that are formed are because of
the very construction of these
properties
it's not just buildings that are poorly
insulated or overheat which pose a risk
to our health and welfare
people nature and infrastructure are all
threatened by climate change
there needs to be much more action from
government they need they're the ones
that need to put the money in
they're the ones need to put
infrastructure in they're the ones with
the regulations and laws to force change
i mean people will will change when they
when they're told to do so and we will
take individual action but we need
support in that
buffeted by extreme weather aberdeen is
a city which sees itself as on the front
line of climate change
in a stark warning the climate change
committee which advises the uk
government how to get to net zero
says the country is unprepared for what
lies ahead
i think the government's response has
been inadequate we've seen the the
the science of climate change has
improved uh progressively over time
we've become more and more aware of the
risks that we face and yet we haven't
seen
a commensurate response from the
government to those risks and it's time
for the government to now act on that
the climate change committee says
ambition needs to be matched with
adaptation and insists we're now in a
critical period
for dealing with the impact of climate
change in the uk
lisa holland sky news aberdeen
[Applause]
and for more stories like that from
people trying to stop
climate change you can watch the daily
climate show on sky news
you can join sam washington this week
and next at 6 30 and 9 30 anna jones on
holiday
or if you're on the go you can download
and listen to the latest edition
of our weekly climate cast broadcast
available
now wherever you get your podcast from
inflation figures what's going on let's
find out our business correspondent
standing by paul kelso hey paul
hi kay yes inflation figures released
this morning
for may show that inflation has risen
again we saw a steep rise in april
it's gone up again in may to a headline
figure of 2.1
so increasing prices first question is
why
well we're out there spending again the
economy is back up and running
uh perhaps a little faster than some
people would like these are year-on-year
figures so compare them in our minds
to may last year when we were still
locked down where a price is rising
while the cost of fuel diesel and petrol
at the pump is up because oil is more
expensive
but also the stuff perhaps we're we're
happier to see back recreation and
culture
eating out and drinking the cost of that
has
all increased according to the office
for national statistics
that shows we are back out uh their
spending uh
the issue uh for those providing us with
those goods as we know there are supply
problems while demand has increased and
there's pent-up demand people
lucky enough to keep their jobs have
been sitting on savings they're now
spending it
suppliers have been struggling to get
goods to us we know there's a supply
chain problem around
the world the next question is what
might the bank of england do about it
because this figure today 2.1 percent
is above the two percent target that the
bank of england
works on it's actually going faster than
the bank thought in their
uh report earnings they didn't expect it
to
get past two percent until later this
year there's no expectation they'll
adjust
interest rates they certainly don't want
to till next year but the longer prices
increase the more pressure they'll be on
the bank to think about trying to
damp down inflation because things are
very very fragile in the economy
furlough's about to be withdrawn there
are no no easy
decisions but prices are on the up okay
paul
thanks talking about fuel prices there
um
talking about what happens when you go
green next because having raced the most
powerful petrol cars
in the world former f1 champion nico
rosberg is trying to turn the world
green
he's leaning the green tech festival
which promotes the latest high-tech
solutions
for combating climate change and he's
with us now hello to you
hello okay thanks for having me on the
show oh thanks for joining us um tell us
about the green tech festival
yeah so green tech festival i founded it
uh three years ago actually here in
berlin and i'm sitting in berlin now
because it's
it's on this week um and it's really
bringing together the world's leading
change makers
um because i myself also want to take
part in what you were having on the show
before
and in in fighting climate change
because it's such an important decade
now
and uh and in the festival this uh this
week again we're gathering some of the
world's leading change makers for
example robert redford
uh jane goodall is participat
participating as well
i'm gutted that because of kovitz she's
going to have to participate virtually
um but anyways it's still nice to have
her uh brian
adams is going to be performing you know
so it's a great week ahead for us here
and what sort of things will you be
discussing
um so it's really about the latest the
latest for example
first of all also the latest scientific
facts that have arisen
which are the most alarming we're going
to be presenting those discussing those
and then it's all about creating
partnerships and showcasing
the technologies that are really going
to help us most
in this fight against climate change um
and how have you
changed your life would you say um nico
in order to become more climate
conscious to become more green
yeah so as a as i'm making a very
conscious
effort myself in my daily life first of
all with my family at home so no more
plastic at home
or reducing driving an electric car and
also in my businesses that we're always
going climate neutral in all our
businesses we we use a software to
really analyze our
co2 emissions um so it's really about
making an effort and of course
i'm not perfect and we're not perfect
but i think if everybody makes an effort
and does his part then
then we really have uh we can hope that
we can achieve those
ambitious targets that we all need to
get to and you've founded a team haven't
you
in extreme e tell me about extreme e and
about your team
yeah xtreme is a new motorsports series
which uh which really is
is built on this social cause of helping
to fight climate change
um we're racing around the world in in
some of the most extreme locations where
climate change has also
already damaged our environment in the
most severe ways
um so for example we were racing in
senegal the other week
and there the coastline is extremely
eroded there's droughts becoming
a bigger and bigger problem and threat
and so it's so great how we're using
like the sport as a vehicle
to raise awareness and also implement
local
or support local initiatives to then
have local impact
in a positive way so this is what i love
about this new form of motor sports
and the great thing is it's rosberg
against hamilton
because lewis hamilton also has a team
there and it happens to turn out
and it's always the two of us fighting
for the wins uh
for now i've been able to take the first
two wins home with my team
lewis was mostly second with his team
but it's so lip and tuck
and so it's a great revival of our
battle there as well and are you more
electric
or synthetic feel
yeah so this xtreme category is
completely electric um
i am it really depends i'm open-minded i
mean for
four road cars electric is the way to go
but synthetic fuels will definitely have
their use case as well
uh we might look at aviation for that or
even shipping
um so certainly there they will be they
will be a great use case for the future
and let's not forget formula one as well
i really hope and believe
that formula one could be the platform
to really make
giant leaps in the development of these
synthetic fuels um that would be
fantastic
um just before i let you go excuse me my
son is a massive petrol head i don't
know if we can call them petrol heads in
future but
he he watches uh formula one every time
it's racing i think it's uh this week
isn't it in france but he more generally
he wants me to ask you is there a chance
that toto wolff may swap
valtteri bottas for george russell
mid-season if he keeps underperforming
to ensure mercedes win the constructors
championship
yeah so that's the big question of the
moment um i think from a british british
perspective you can be really excited
about the future because you have two
extremely talented up and coming drivers
you've got lando norris
george russell and george russell of
course being a mercedes driver
so certainly total wolf it's now
mid-season so certainly he's going to be
thinking about it very very carefully
and it's difficult to know which way
he's going to go um but of course
george russell would definitely be a
great asset to team mercedes
even though we have to say that valtteri
bottas has also been
contributing very very strongly in the
last years such a diplomatic answer what
do you think he should do
um ah that's that's not it's not
something i think you should do i think
from a
fan perspective it would be interesting
to now have a change
and to have someone new in that second
car alongside lewis
someone who's really going to give lewis
a run for his money within the same team
a young guy who can maybe uh re
replace lewis as number one driver in
the future than a mercedes so from that
point of view i think from
all the fans perspective we would be
quite happy uh to see a change there and
see something new
okay nico it's great to talk to you
thanks for joining us again on the
program you're always welcome whenever
you want to come along thank you
thanks a lot okay bye-bye take care uh
let's find out what's happening doing my
research
quick look at the weather here's hey nas
hello
hi good morning it's uh going to be a
hot and humid one across southern and
eastern areas where we're likely to see
the highest temperature of the year so
far
mostly fine and dry elsewhere bit of
cloud and drizzle for [ __ ]
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning there will be heat and
humidity for southern and eastern areas
for today where we're likely to see the
highest temperature of the year so far
beating the record
which was only set on monday 29.7
degrees celsius
in teddington i think locally we could
see highs of 30 to 31 degrees celsius
somewhere around the southeast or
eastern england
but generally speaking it's going to be
fine and warm for many areas today
temperatures more around average for the
time of year across ireland northern
ireland scotland where for
most across these parts it would be
bright or sunny but some scattered
showers across the northwest
cloudy cool and murky with uh patchy
rain and drizzle for
southern scotland northwest england the
western wales and the south west
the rest of england and wales will be
sunny and very warm locally hot hot
south and eastern thunderstorms tonight
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
what if we'll call petrol heads electric
heads in future
still to come this morning for you how
much damage has the scandal around the
diana interview done to the bbc
we'll talk to former bbc governor sir
richard air in just a few minutes
[Music]
well it kind of made all the difference
really and it wasn't just the birds song
it was the landscapes then
they inhabited um and um i suppose
these events smash and bash their way
into your life without permission and
i found birdsong the perfect inbuilt
coping mechanism for me it it
it affects you and your nature does
stuff to you that you don't know it's
doing
and i are doing to you and i you know
had ignored
these beautiful sounds for so long
um and and and nature i'd got on with my
life i'm not a bird watcher or an
ornithologist and
it's like so much old wallpaper all
around you these these sparrows and
these robins and these black birds and
green finches
and it just by tuning in just helped
give
my life perspective and take me away
from myself i suppose
i live near the pewsie vale i was up on
the downlands there
at one of the one of the lowest points
of my my life really mom had just been
diagnosed with terminal cancer and given
a very short amount of time to live and
no one prepares you for bad news in life
and lying there
listening to a skylark or a skylark
suddenly started singing above me and
there's something it's like a injection
of neat hope to the soul
um and um it made me realize that when
was the last time that i actually sat
and listened to the song of a bird and
and it really was the start of a journey
of of tuning in again
to everything that i had ignored for so
long we overthink life
the only point of life is is just to
live and i think the birds and the
sparrows they show us they just get on
no matter what our problems are
you know what it taught me i suppose i'm
no longer the lead role
in my own private melodrama but just a
bit part
in nature's great epic you know this
great around us going on
whatever's happening in our wider life
[Music]
we are at a breaking point and we need
to work
now and fast even though young people
are vulnerable
to the import of climate change young
people can also become the change agents
that we need to address the climate
impact
in my campaign or in advocacy work i
work largely with young people
so that their voices can be heard so
they can also influence
decision making from the local level to
the national level and thankfully
we are making progress in a regard
[Music]
[Music]
the former director general of the bbc
has admitted he was wrong
not to sack martin beshear over the way
he secured an
interview with diana princess of wales
tony hall cleared martin beshear after
he admitted
using forging banks using forged bank
statements to persuade
the princess to speak well joining us
now from the
uh is the former bbc governor sir
richard hello t thanks for joining us on
the programme this morning
um hiya what did you make of the
explanations from the bbc bosses
i thought they were plausible um for one
reason
my explanation
of the whole uh fiasco
was that the people involved were
consumed
by contagious ambition
blind ambition uh john burt had come
into the bbc as director general the
third in the line the previous two
had been fired by the the chairman
mahmud newcastle
he came in with a specific uh
program of putting news
on the front foot he thought that the
bbc news gathering
and news reporting of the time was very
very
complacent and inward looking so he inc
he was encouraging uh the the
the news department to go on the
front foot now panorama like a number of
bbc
programs it's very self-contained or was
very self-contained it probably still is
semi-autonomous so there was this group
who got this
massive scoop i don't think anybody
or maybe the panorama people were but
certainly not
john bert and tony hall were terribly
interested in how
bashir had got access to princess diana
the whole thing was
very much conducted in in secrecy
everybody outside that inner circle was
astonished that
last year this totally unknown reporter
had got the interview and our questions
were answered
were asked but but none were answered so
i i think that the program
the film panorama was filmed
people say well he forced his way into
dinah i don't think that's true at all
because i think diana was absolutely
delighted
to meet an unknown reporter who wasn't
robin day or some other uh heavyweight
who she could manipulate and if you
remember she was keen to reply
to a very sycophantic documentary a bbc
style documentary
that itv had made the year before which
was
uh a reporter jonathan
will be interviewing prince charles
and she was infuriated by that she saw
this
guy who seemed absolutely charming and
intelligent
and totally sympathetic it was filmed in
secret
it was edited in secret not even the
board of management knew
that it was happening until the film had
been made
and of course the board of governors
weren't told because
john burke wasn't talking literally
wasn't talking
to the chairman of the governors okay so
richard i'm going to have to come in
there if i may because you know
we've all subsequently seen the recent
panorama documentary where
diana was basically uh led to believe
that even her closest allies were
against her and were briefing against
her
and so she felt that she had no option
but to go and put out that story if she
had not been
fed these mistruths and and lies then
potentially she wouldn't have done that
documentary
i i don't think that's true well we
don't know do we we don't know
i think that well we don't know
i don't know you don't know uh all i
know is
that she was infuriated by the
jonathan dimbleby film of prince charles
desperately wanted to talk and along
came this
what to her seemed a perfectly plausible
nice uh and a sympathetic man
but either way the the the um bank
statements were forged
she was duped into believing those
closest to her uh were turning against
her and briefing against her
there has to be some consequence for
that happening we've seen what's
happened to bashir
what about others above him what
consequence should there be for those
senior managers who've either retired
on bbc pensions or are still working at
the bbc
um i simply don't know what possible
punishment there is except shame
i mean i think that tony hall has
suffered um in fact uh i think
excessively um from
the revelations and uh has apologized i
think
john burt has played a very good hand
because of course
he was um editor-in-chief so
i feel he has to take responsibility for
what happened but um what course what
what punishment can there be it's 25 26
years in the past uh the punishment
is um public shame
the future king didn't he stopped short
of saying that you know his mother's
death was
uh eventually as a result of what
happened during this martin
beshear interview where she's
subsequently ostracized by the royal
family
but there has to be some consequence
surely politically surely there has to
be some consequence for the bbc
well the bbc politicians have never
liked the bbc they can't bear the idea
that a state
broadcasting company is independent of
the state
and doesn't work doesn't obey the
the mandate of the state and also they
hate the idea that it's paid by
a hypothetic tax so the treasury can't
play around with attacks
um what can they do well they can
you know cut legs off the the bbc
uh that would be an act of massive
cultural vandalism the bbc is
the most important cultural organization
in the world and i very much hope that
it's going to
have the power to remain so it's good to
talk to you sadly we're out of time but
um it's a topic that hopefully we will
return to and be able to speak to you
again in more detail thank you
thank you campaigners are calling on the
government
to honor a commitment to double dementia
research funding more than 50 000 people
have signed a petition saying the
illness
is now the biggest long-term challenge
that we face
joining us is the actor stephen
thompkinson who sadly lost his dad
to dementia in 2015 and he's with us now
hello to you thanks for joining
us talk to us about your dad morning
chase good morning
uh yeah dad suffered for
seven years with dementia and it's a
very
long and very painful process where
you just lose more of them every day
you're left with a sort of outside
shelf and the person that you knew has
been
taken from you it's incredibly painful
um but as soon as dad had eventually
passed away
i i didn't want anyone else to suffer in
the same way so i i contacted
alzheimer's research uk to see if there
was anything that i could do to help
their cause and i've been involved with
them ever since
government promised at the last election
i think in brighton's saying to double
its investment
into dementia research to more than 160
million pounds a year
um doesn't look as though they've
fulfilled that as of yet
um as a campaigner how does that make
you
very angry um you know i'm sure
this government won't be the first
government to make
election promises that they they don't
deliver on but this is
two years down the line they were trying
to secure votes of that they
they got those votes uh they promised
that they would double the research to
160 million
pounds a year which sounds an awful lot
but at the moment there is
no nothing to prevent alzheimer's
there's nothing to cure it and it's
costing our economy 26 billion
pounds a year uh so we're not asking
for we're just asking them to honor
their promise
you know it's it's a very basic thing
what would that money be used for what
what could the 160 million pounds a year
do uh well
you know alzheimer's research uk are
looking into
all kinds of avenues to you know we've
got to try
and find that in america the
the moving a little quicker with
uh drugs that can actually
uh sort of deal with the amyloid which
is a build up of protein
uh in the brain and that that
then goes on to cause dementia and
there's uh
there's more progress being made in
america with diseases
uh with cure for diseases or hoping to
stop diseases and
we would like the government to
accelerate their
funding and honor their promises and
hopefully
find some way of stopping and eventually
curing this disease which
is going is does one in two of us know
someone that's affected by dementia
at the moment uh we are living longer as
a society so it's going to be a bigger
and bigger problem
there's 600 children born every day
who will develop dementia and it
surely it's time to stop okay
it i'm sorry about about the loss of of
your dad but i'm sure that um
he was very proud of you um when he was
able to communicate with you
uh more fully thank you so much for
joining us appreciate it
thank you thanks a lot
still to come
we'll talk to the doctors using
tick-tock videos to combat
misinformation about the coronavirus
vaccines that's next
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
they have breached the road there is a
lot of
gas being
[Music]
i
[Music]
it is an am carnival kind of atmosphere
out here for prime minister modi
these students and now they're going to
be arrested
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
[Applause]
the roads have been inundated the only
way out
is to get people by boat
what is fear that over 200 people might
have died because of these landslides
[Music]
this on any given day would have been
bustling with people but today
it's absolutely deserted
this is one of the most sensitive areas
of of northeast delhi where there's been
clashes
i'm never lazarus and i'm skies reporter
based in delhi
i'm coming from a family of fishermen
actually my family has been fishermen
for five generations
[Music]
the fishermen cut this blast by accident
so we give them the motivation
and the system to bring back to the land
we have collected already more than
110 000 kilos of plastic from the bottom
of the sea
did you know pollen levels tend to be
higher in the morning
and at night the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
purifiers
most of southern scotland the north and
west of england and the west of wales
will be rather cloudy cool and murky
this afternoon with light rain and
drizzle
elsewhere will be fine warm and sunny
but hot and humid
for central southern and eastern england
where thunderstorms are likely into
tonight
so grass pollen is now in peak season
fungal spores are at a medium risk and
there's lots of weed pollen about too
polar levels will be high or very high
for england today
and high for much of wales whereas
northern ireland will be moderate and
scotland will be low once again
the pollen reports sponsored by phillips
connected air purifiers
now two young doctors have begun a
social media campaign to combat
misinformation about the coronavirus
vaccine
tasnim jarrah and will bod have made a
series of videos to persuade people to
get their jab
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
well doctors and team halo members will
bod
and tas named jarrah are with us now
hello to you both thanks for joining us
this morning ladies
first tasnim um tell us how you came up
with this idea
well i've been working as an a e doctor
at bathing stock in north hampshire
hospital throughout this pandemic
and i've seen firsthand how devastating
kovid can be to a family
but then i come home and see these
stories online saying that
kovit's not real or promoting harmful
practices
guaranteeing as a definite cure for
covid or
scare stories that are trying to
convince people not to take the vaccine
and very early on in the pandemic public
health england published a report
saying that people from military
background had the highest risk of death
so that really worried me and i thought
if people understood
the evidence behind covert and coveted
vaccines potentially lives can be saved
and i know the language very well i
understand the evidence so i started
making these short videos
explaining how people can protect
themselves from covered why they need
the vaccine
and just helping people make decisions
based on science not rumors
and will why tick tock in particular
well tick tock is one of the fastest
growing and social media platforms and
the ability to make videos that have
green screens and use video sessions
in mind where you can use old videos as
well and we just can go
viral on there as well as you can reach
a much larger audience and if you pack
the information into some patches people
watch it and
you know every day seeing that they
might learn and it may help them make a
decision
and well i'm guessing you have some
concern about
misinformation that is spreading on
platforms like tick tock will
yeah absolutely i mean all social media
misinformation can spread just like the
virus can
and the issue is when it comes to
ingredients of people's beliefs it's
quite hard to change their mind then so
a lot of people
will get a lot of news from social media
and that's fine if they're using like
registered channels such as
news or bbc but when people start
believing things deliberate
misinformation
and tesla um talk to me about team halo
what what is that and how does that
incorporate into what you're trying to
do
so team halo is a group of scientists
and doctors like me
we volunteer our time to make short
videos
engaging and fun we hope to address
vaccine misinformation
so we make these videos to unpack the
covid related misinformation and the
misinformation related to vaccines
to answer people's queries and respond
to their concerns
and give out bits of relevant bits of
information that become relevant with
time
and like will said there's so much of
information and medical misinformation
on these social media platforms
that it's difficult for people to
understand which is based on evidence
and which is not
and we can't reasonably expect that
everyone will know the scientific method
or be able to critically evaluate the
claims and see that whether that's based
on evidence
which is why i think we need more and
more experts
engage on social media platforms break
down the complex topics and explain them
in a way that everyone can understand
which is why i think the work that my
colleagues are doing at team halo is so
crucial and so important
and well what experience have you had uh
dealing with
uh covert 19 uh
in terms of weapon hospital uh
so i work on the vaccine trials and i'm
here in college so it's been a bit
different it's been to me i haven't seen
so much
patients that most younger doctors have
seen in hospitals but it's been
really interesting to get a grip of how
the back team worked
to run the trials you know we couldn't
have done it about the volunteers
there's a big thank you out there
everyone who volunteered for the trials
um it's been interesting to see
how uh even all other health has changed
over the course of the 19th so the
and which needs to be addressed um but
yeah for me it's been
quite an unusual experience hopefully to
get out as soon as possible
okay good to talk to both of you thanks
a lot for joining us appreciate it thank
you
thank you um all the time the government
is bringing down the age at which
uh people can have their vaccination
they're hoping that all
adults by the end of the week will uh be
able to make their first
appointment for a covid19 vaccine
and as you know at the moment we haven't
been able to do that which is
why we've had to according to the
government we've had to
extend to the 19th of july now called
terminus
day quick look at the weather final
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning it's all going on today
we've got a little bit of everything
for the vast majority it's looking fine
and dry with some good spells of
sunshine but for some
it's cloudy cool murky with patchy light
rain and drizzle
currently across southern and eastern
parts of ireland the east of northern
ireland
southern parts of scotland north west
england the west of wales and
edging into the south west of england
mainly around cornwall
and we'll see little change on that into
this afternoon perhaps becoming a bit
brighter for
eastern parts of ireland northern
ireland but southern scotland northwest
england the west of wales and southwest
continue with the cloudy conditions
coastal fog likely still and patchy like
rain and drizzle although the
drizzle should tend to ease for the rest
of england and wales it's looking very
warm locally hot across parts of the
south and east where we're likely to see
the highest temperature of the year so
far
somewhere around the southeast or
eastern england i think could locally
see highs of 30 to 31 degrees celsius
temperatures more around average for the
rest of ireland northern ireland and
scotland so a warm enough day in the
sunny spells but somewhat cloudier and
there will be some showers across
northern western parts where it will be
quite windy too
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
coming up in the next outfie here on the
breakfast show we've been
talking to government minister liz truss
following reports that coronavirus
vaccines are to be mandatory for
staffing care homes
apparently we're going to be hearing
more from her very shortly
here on the programmed
[Music]
a few years ago my partner alex and i
realized that there was a huge issue
with the way cleaning products are being
sold
[Music]
the family could only be bought in
plastic bottles and once used these
cheap bottles would inevitably break and
end up in landfill
since launching we've so far saved over
10 000
plastic spray bottles from ending up in
landfill
do
[Music]
hi everyone it is nine o'clock here in
the uk you're very welcome wherever you
are watching us
right around the world this morning when
boris johnson confirmed
that the easing of lockdown measures in
england was being delayed he said
it was still allowed for more people to
be vaccinated now there are plans for
jabs to be made compulsory for all care
home staff
looking after the elderly the
international trade secretary liz trust
has suggested
she's in favor of the idea also this
morning
let's do business the mayor of london's
leak khan on why he's calling for more
financial support
for firms until all coveted restrictions
are dropped
he's with us at 9 20 and we'll also
bring you
live coverage as lord frost gives
evidence to a parliamentary committee
about the ongoing row over the northern
ireland brexit
agreement it's wednesday the 16th of
june
a job for a job it's understood covered
vaccinations will be made compulsory for
care home staff who work with the
elderly
i would want the staff to be vaccinated
of course i would
because i would want my parent to be
protected
a failure to weather the storm
scientists say the uk is less prepared
to deal with climate change now
than it was five years ago there needs
to be much more action from government
they need they're the ones that need to
put the money in
they're the ones need to put
infrastructure in they're the ones with
the regulations and laws to force change
israel launches airstrikes in gaza the
military says it's in retaliation for
incendiary balloons
fired from the territory
presidential summit but will joe biden's
meeting with vladimir putin
follow convention in geneva
a bigger than expected rise in the cost
of living last month inflation is now
running ahead of the bank of england
target
and it's looking fine and sunny for most
places today but for some cloudy cool
and murky
as well as damp hot and humid in the
southeast where we could see the highest
temperature of the year so far before
thunderstorms tonight
i'll have all the details later
[Music]
morning everyone now if you work in a
care home looking after elderly or
vulnerable people then you'll have to
have a coronavirus vaccination
ministers want to make the jobs
mandatory and has said
to want to extend the move to cover all
nhs staff
in the last hour i asked the
international trade secretary liz trust
to confirm
whether it was going to happen everybody
who has the opportunity for a vaccine
should take up that opportunity because
it's helped
protect all of us and keep all of us
safe okay sacked if they don't have one
two i i i'm not gonna comment
because we haven't we haven't got the
well we haven't responded to the
consultation it'd be responsibly wrong
of me
to prejudge that consultation but it's
clearly
if you had a parent who was in a care
home i would want to make sure
i would want the staff to be vaccinated
of course i would
because i would want my parent to be
protected
well also this morning the leader of the
house of commons jacob rees-mogg has
suggested the lockdown can't continue
just to protect the nhs government
policy is that the lockdown is needed
to protect the nhs but speaking on his
podcast jacob rees-mock said the nhs is
there to serve the british people
not the british people to serve the nhs
i put that to liz trust i agree with him
that lockdown
shouldn't drag on we want to bring an
end to it we've already
taken a number of steps to open up uh
parts of the economy
things are freer than they were a few
months ago
but i think we need to hold our nerve to
make sure
that we keep levels of the virus down
and the way to do that is through
vaccination
also said that the government's new
agreement with australia will protect
british farmers
she assured me the post-brexit deal
contained clauses to stop the uk market
being flooded by australian produce
what we are doing is we're making sure
there's a transition period for farmers
of 15 years
so we're going to give australia the
same access
that the eu have to our market in 15
years time
the eu already has quota free access
to the uk so they already sell us 230
000
tonnes of beef per year what this deal
is talking about
is next year it'll be 35 000 tons so we
we import far more beef from the eu than
we do
from australia and what we're talking
about is rectifying that in 15 years
time
demarcoin is with us but what that
what's that going to mean um tomorrow
as far as northern ireland negotiations
with the european union are concerned
well okay as we know uh the uk and the
eu are in a standoff over
this issue of northern ireland and what
checks should take place
on trade between northern ireland and
the rest of the uk
and the and the difficulty uh with this
trade deal the government is very
pleased to have done a trade deal with
australia the first
from scratch since we left the eu
is that of course um the the issue of
getting rid of all tariffs and making it
easier for australian products
like wines to come to the uk and for
british products like cars and whiskey
and so on to go to australia is
what view is the eu going to take of
this in northern ireland because they're
already concerned
that products from the uk are will are
one are coming to northern ireland and
the and the british side don't want
to do the checks that the eu are
demanding if
britain starts doing trade deals with
australia and potentially a whole host
of other countries
that is going to in the eu's view again
threaten
the integrity of the single market risk
that products get into the single market
that haven't had checks
uh done on them properly and so that may
complicate things
as regards solving the dispute and don't
forget this dispute does need to be
solved
quickly because when the northern
ireland protocol
was signed back in december a series of
grace
periods were agreed one of them on
chilled meat which is why we have what's
been called the sausage war
that expires in just two weeks time and
unless a compromise is made
between the uk and the eu then imports
of chilled meat
to northern ireland from the uk will be
banned
so how does this new trade deal that was
announced yesterday
complicate things as regards solving the
northern ireland dispute where we'll be
hearing from the brexit minister lord
frost later this morning
we certainly will in about 25 minutes
time in fact
for now thanks so much indeed tomorrow
thank you still to come on the programme
for you
the mayor of london sleek calm wants the
government to provide financial support
for businesses until all kovid
restrictions are dropped
we'll talk to him in a few moments then
at 9 30 we'll bring you at the said live
coverage as lord frost gives evidence
to a parliamentary committee about the
ongoing row
over the northern ireland protocol
meantime the uk it appears is even less
prepared to deal with climate change
conditions
hitting the country today than it was
five years ago
that's according to the government's own
climate change experts they say
new build homes are poorly designed and
can't cope with the impact of rising
temperatures
here's our climate change correspondent
lisa holland
with rock from local quarries aberdeen
is known as the granite city
distinctive architecture but old granite
buildings are notoriously difficult to
keep warm
this is the cavity and this cavity is
ventilated to
under the floor and this is vital in
order to keep the inner wall
here dry engineer david mcgrath is
developing ways to make
homes more energy efficient and is
insulating his
son's granite house in aberdeen he
believes not enough is being done to
help
people retrofit their homes for all
properties
like this is vitally important in on two
fronts one
we have to do some mitigation for
climate change
but actually a lot of the illnesses that
are formed are because of the very
construction of these properties
it's not just buildings that are poorly
insulated or overheat which pose
a risk to our health and welfare people
nature and infrastructure are all
threatened by climate change
there needs to be much more action from
government they need they're the ones
that need to put the money in
they're the ones need to put
infrastructure in they're the ones with
the regulations and laws to force change
i mean people will will change when they
when they're told to do so and we will
take individual action but we need
support in that
buffeted by extreme weather aberdeen is
a city which sees itself as on the front
line of climate change
in a stark warning the climate change
committee which advises the uk
government how to get to net zero
says the country is unprepared for what
lies ahead i think the government's
response has been inadequate we've seen
the the the science of climate change
has improved
uh progressively over time we've become
more and more aware of the risks that we
face and yet we haven't seen
a commensurate response from the
government to those risks and it's time
for the government to now act on that
the climate change committee says
ambition needs to be matched with
adaptation and insists we're now in a
critical period
for dealing with the impact of climate
change in the uk
lisa holland sky news aberdeen
[Applause]
and for more news like that and stories
from the people trying to stop
climate change you can watch the daily
climate show on sky news
you can join sam washington this week
and next uh
6 30 and 9 30 anna jones on holiday
or if you're on the go you can download
and listen to the latest edition
of our weekly climate cast podcast
available
wherever you get your podcast from
also making the news for you
israel says it has launched airstrikes
in the gaza strip
in retaliation for incendiary balloons
fired from the territory
it's the first major clash since 11 days
of fighting between the two sides ended
late last month
china has confirmed it will launch its
first manned space mission in
five years tomorrow morning three
astronauts are due to spend several
months aboard
a space station and will also carry out
a space
walk more than four
billion dollars has been wiped off the
coca-cola share price because of
him doing that cristiano ronaldo
moved the coke bottles from the desk
during his euro 2020 news conference he
then toasted
with a bottle of water
two of the most powerful world leaders
come face to face later on today when
joe biden and vladimir putin meet in
switzerland
takes place just days after president
putin said relations
between russia and the united states
were at the lowest point
let's find out more about what's likely
to happen our u.s correspondent mark
stone has traveled to geneva
and he is with us now um hello to you um
mark so they've got to sort of uh zone
around where the two guys will be
meeting that's hermetically sealed no
one can get in
or out what might come of this meeting
yeah except for us kay we've been
allowed uh pretty close as part of a
media
pool and you can see that the stage is
set the red carpet is out
at a historic villa here on the shores
of lake geneva for a summit that is
certainly historic whether or not it
will um
yield any concrete diplomatic solutions
for this very very
difficult relationship well um i don't
think so diplomats on both sides are um
playing down any suggestion that there
will be a light bulb moment
between these two leaders i think
they've got an awful lot
to discuss when they arrive here at
lunchtime for meetings that will last
through the afternoon both sides are
going to want to
push different issues from the american
perspective there will be issues of
of human rights alexey navalny of course
the opposition leader
in russia poisoned and then imprisoned
in russia
remains in prison uh president putin was
asked a couple of days ago about that
case and he said if
mr navalny was to die in prison that
would be on putin so there are there are
human rights issues that clearly from an
american
domestic perspective mr biden will want
to be seen to be tough on mr putin on
there
um there is some criticism of mr biden
that he's decided to have this meeting
or
to grant it from his perspective um so
early in his presidency being seen
perhaps to reward
president putin and then there are the
much much bigger global
geopolitical issues that they will need
to discuss
as you said the relationship is at an
all-time low at the moment
perhaps not an all-time low but it does
certainly feel like the cold war
is back and so i suppose in that context
the fact that they're meeting at all
is positive you can see some of the
media gathered
around here there are various different
media sites this is the closest
uh site that we're able to get there are
others down the road in in this
large park and um there will be press
conferences later on at one stage we
wondered whether
uh there might be a joint press
conference remember when mr putin met
mr trump three years ago that was a a
low point in diplomatic relations and
they did hold a joint and very difficult
news conference today
uh the news conferences will be separate
uh to prevent any um
diplomatic moments uh but by questioning
from from the media so we'll hear
from mr biden and mr putin but
separately and i think there will be a
desire by both sides to draw red lines
on certain key issues from the russian
perspective
there is the issue of ukraine a
suggestion from the americans that
perhaps ukraine could join nato
that is a hard red line as one russian
diplomat said to me yesterday
the idea from a russian perspective of
ukraine joining nato
that would mean war russia believes that
the buffer that ukraine
geographically has between the west and
and the russian federation
that is very important so a very very
difficult summit many issues to be
discussed
don't expect big headlines at the end of
it okay mark thank you
um meantime let's find out what's
happening as far as the business news is
concerned
here heart of the city ian king standing
by hi ian good morning
hello okay we've had the latest
inflation figures out this morning from
the office for national statistics i'm
pretty chilling they are too if
you take these things seriously a lot of
people seem to be fairly
blithe about inflation these days so the
number for may
the consumer prices inflation it rose to
2.1 percent
that was up from one and a half percent
in april and if you cast your mind back
to march when the figure was just 0.7
percent
it means that inflation has trebled in
just two months it's at a 22-year high
you have to go back to those good old
days prior to the pandemic july 2019
for the time when uh cpi was higher than
this and of course
it means that the rate of inflation is
above the bank of england's target rate
now the contributory factors here
clothing motor fuel computer games and
meals
eating out drinking out it's obviously
something a lot of us have been able to
do
for a while those are the main factors
uh behind
this rise in inflation and uh that last
point about eating out it really uh kind
of explains why the bank of england
and other commentators are fairly
relaxed about this they say that this is
a transitory rise in inflation that's
the jargon effectively that this is just
a result of bottlenecks that have built
up
during the pandemic and pent-up demand
being spent but there are other people
who think that this is actually
a sign of deeper seated inflation rises
to come you might recall i've been
talking about this
for a while now rises in a lot of
commodity prices and in fact the price
of oil has this morning
hit its highest level since april 2019
so again that's a big contributor to
inflation as i say the bank of england
has so far insisted that this is only a
temporary rise in inflation that expects
to come down
in due course but andrew bailey the
governor did say
fairly recently that the bank wouldn't
hesitate to raise interest rates
if he thought that the inflation rate
was going to remain above the target
level
um for a protected period of time now
it's also worth pointing out okay this
is not just
a uk phenomenon in america the latest
inflation
figures there which were released at the
tail end of last week show cpi
of 5 and again the federal reserve in
the us
is insisting that this is transitory and
accordingly it's not rushing to raise
interest rates or cut back on its
quantitative easing either
however it is certainly uh a straw in
the wind for
people who are very concerned about
inflation and uh
viewers with long memories thinking back
to the 1970s
and the early 1980s will recall that
once the inflation genie is out of the
bottle
it's very hard to get it back in again
okay for now thank you thanks a lot ian
ian coming up
about 10 o'clock now the recalls this
morning for urgent reform of the care
system
in england the house of commons public
accounts committee
says there needs to be proper funding
and once the pandemic has had what it
calls a devastating impact
fraser moore reports
enjoying the sunshine and some
traditional seaside fun the residents of
saint cecilia's
in scarborough here as in hundreds of
other care homes
lives have been lost during the pandemic
taking a toll on the residents their
families
and the staff those who work in the care
sector
say today's report by the public
accounts committee doesn't tell them
anything new
they know action is needed and with many
homes now operating at only 80
capacity they need it to happen soon i'd
like the government to be bold and
committed and to actually give us a date
when it's
going to start and finish the reforms
really if they can't do that then i
suggest someone else comes in
and and actually does it because we've
heard promises broken promises
over more than two decades and enough is
enough it's about time someone stood up
and said
this is when it's happening the report
concludes that care is not properly
funded
lacks transparency and urgently needs
reform
we've said really that the government
has failed on social care and not just
the devastation that it faced during
covid but it has a track record that we
have highlighted a number of times
not delivering on many aspects of
supporting people in care homes and
getting care at home
residents like david who's been at
centercelius for seven years
greatly appreciate the work of their
carers they're worth the white team gold
they come here at seven o'clock in the
morning ready for work and they don't
get um tonight at night and leave it out
that's a long shift you know and they're
on the face imagine the mortgages
they're walking around all the time
you know just phenomenal the staff
themselves
love their jobs but often feel
undervalued
you can't teach someone to care they
either have
care or they don't have care and to be
able to look after people
especially with the needs that our our
residents have
that it takes some doing today's report
calls for this government to finally
deliver the reforms that have long been
promised
starting with an outline by next month
on how much support is needed
to cope with the immediate crisis caused
by kovid 19.
fraser moored sky news scarborough
pleased to say the mayor of london is
with us this morning sadiq
khan he wants the furloughs to scheme i
should say extended
until businesses are back on their feet
again and he's with us now
um hello to you uh mr mayor thank you
for joining us
um you want the business rate holiday
and the end of the fellow scheme to be
extended further what difference will it
make
well look i'm here in the heart of our
city in the piccadilly
and we're all disappointed by the
decision by the government for good
reasons actually
to delay the reopening by four weeks so
what we're saying to
the government is not to reduce business
support in the
meantime these businesses are in life
support
uh they will they will delay a full
reopening by four weeks and so it
doesn't make sense
for the business rates relief to be
reduced for the
moratorium on evictions to be stopped
and for them to have to pay towards the
furlough scheme at a time
when they can't fully reopen and in
london one out of five of our jobs
are in retail hospitality or culture we
desperately need
these businesses to flourish and thrive
yeah i mean one of the challenges i'm
guessing for the businesses and
households
in london um is the 337
000 of them that are going to be
affected by the extension of the ultra
low emissions zone i think in october
are you potentially thinking about
extending that now
uh mr mayor to to give businesses and
households a little bit more time
well the ultra mission zone already
covers this part of london we introduced
it in
2017 in central london it's led to
an almost 50 reduction in toxic air from
october
we're going to extend it to the north
circular and south circular because we
believe other parts of london
should also benefit from cleaner air for
us it's an issue of social justice the
poorest children
the poorest londoners that suffer the
worst air and what the
world's first ultra emission zone has
shown is we can
clean the air in london with good bold
policies and i intend to extend it to
the north circular
and the south circular from this exobar
to make sure all more londoners
can benefit from our policies and you
wouldn't you wouldn't consider extending
that uh deadline to maybe towards the
end of the year because as you say these
businesses who aren't necessarily right
in the middle of london
but they will be commuting around the
north south circular
and they have those challenges
we've looked into actually it's a
pro-business policy because when you
look at the impact on productivity
with soft taking time off because of
asthma heart disease cancer
and other issues related to poor quality
here when you look at the cost to the
nhs with some of the issues we have
because of poor culture
actually it's both pro-business and
pro-social justice so we're going to you
know go ahead
with making sure london is a green city
and we have a green recovery
very keen to get the vaccines out as
well aren't you i know you were here on
sky news about a month or so ago asking
for jabs for younger people in parts of
london
where the delta variant had been
detected what did the government say in
response to that
wilson can i just pay tribute to nadeem
sahari the government vaccines minister
he's been a joy to work with
working closely with the government to
make sure we can have more of particular
the fisa vaccine and the modern vaccine
in london and why do i say that
because our population is younger than
other parts of the country you'll be
aware you reported on some of the
concerns
around az for younger people and the
good news is so we're hoping over the
course of the next few days and weeks
for more of those vaccines because we're
hoping later on this week
uh more of those over the age of 18
currently is
21 and above from later on this week
it'll be above the age of 18 and this
weekend
you'll be seeing huge events across
london where anybody above the age
above the age of 18 can come along and
receive their jab and this jab
is the game changer the more of us that
receive not one but both jobs that means
that we're less likely
to either catch the delta variant or if
we do catch it unfortunately
uh the consequences are less serious and
i spoke yesterday
to my team at the nhs and the good news
is and we're seeing very very few people
in intensive care very
view people on ventilators even fewer
people are losing their lives that's
thanks to this fantastic vaccine
yeah i mean i worked in a vaccine hub
mr mayor and it was very tricky to
organize the fisa vaccines and
we eventually had to rely on the army to
try to move the vaccine
around the country and particularly
around the capital
in your experience from what you're
saying is is that now changing
yeah and uh i always want to thank we've
got in london the london fire brigade
who'll be assisting us
the issue with advisor your spot on is
the refrigeration and the
the defrosting basically uh we've now
got across london
really good systems in place for the the
defrosting of the of the pfizer making
sure we can get doses out across
london the huge advantage okay of the
mass vaccination centers
is because there there are lots of
people coming to one centre it's far
easier to handle the visor we're also
hoping to get modern as well across
london but also don't forget az
we're still using for the second doses
we've made big progress catching up with
the second doses if you remember when we
were speaking
a few few months ago we were concerned
about this word hesitancy
people not keen to receive the job we've
made huge progress
make sure londoners are confident about
the job not just those who were
kobe deniers or anti-vaxxers but those
who had
legitimate concerns about the fact is
we've done a great job making sure
londoners and those across the country
are more confident and i want to thank
all those
nhs staff volunteers and others who've
done a good job in that area
okay mr mayor i must ask you while i've
got you if you'll indulge me as far as
uh the commissioner is concerned
cressida dick
um she has been criticized for
personally placing hurdles in the way
in the search for the truth of the
murder of daniel morgan does she still
have your full support this morning
she does but i should begin by paying
tribute to daniel morgan's family for
their campaigning
over the last 34 years you know
investigation
after investigation has been blighted by
the words of panel
corruption and obstruction from police
officers whose job it is
to investigate serious crimes and i
can't think of a more serious crime than
murder in london we have one of the most
respected anti-corruption commands
we've got strategies dealing with
anti-fraud and anti-corruption
and also whistle-blowing policy as well
the commission is working incredibly
hard
to earn the trust confidence of london
as londoners should feel
confident that the police service in
2021 is
a million years away from the police
service in 1987.
notwithstanding that the panel is uh has
had a
full report 1200 pages we've got to
follow the report
follow the recommendations and make sure
that we earn back the trust confidence
of families like the morgan family going
forward
but the report and the panel did say
that the commissioner personally placed
hurdles in the way in the search for
truth
in this young monster
look uh we're going to look at the
recommendations from the panel
we'll make sure we act upon them uh
crested
dick became the commissioner four years
ago uh the paddle
report goes back 34 years and they make
a comment you're correct
about how ella's the assistant
commissioner she's quite clear
the senior team are quite clear they
will continue to do whatever they can to
investigate this horrible murder but
also makes your lessons alone
and she has your full support this
morning and londoners waking up this
morning should have full um
faith in the commissioner
i i've got full confidence in the
commissioner londoners stuart as well
but londoners should be
assured that at 32 000 heroic
brave police officers and thousands of
police staff
find the report appalling they're going
to make sure that we're learning lessons
that need to be
learned and the police service today is
a million miles from the police service
34 years ago but there are still lessons
we can learn and if there are we will
learn them
okay it's good to talk to you mr marino
you've got another busy day
running the city we'll let you go thank
you
uh it looks pretty sunny doesn't it
where the mare is let's find out for the
rest of us now standing by morning nas
good morning yes there will be lots of
sunshine about four today and for some
it's going to be hot and humid we're
likely to see the highest temperature of
the year so far before we have
thunderstorms
into tonight and for much of the rest of
the week
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning it's going to be fine and
sunny for the vast majority of the uk
and ireland today but for some
it's going to be rather cloudy murky and
cool with patchy light rain and drizzle
mainly this afternoon across southern
parts of scotland at the northwest of
england western parts of wales and down
towards parts of cornwall
at first it will be rather cloudy and
murky with patchy light rain and drizzle
as well across the eastern parts of
ireland
northern ireland but that should be
clearing away we'll see brighter spells
there
and there will be sunny spells for
island northern ireland the rest of
scotland but scattered showers across
the windy north and west whereas for the
rest of england and wales
it will be very warm locally hot across
parts of the south and east where
we could literally see highs around 30
to 31 degrees celsius making it the
highest temperature of the year so far
before tonight
thunderstorms spreading northwards
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
coming up we're going to be hearing from
the brexit minister lord frost he's due
to give evidence to the northern ireland
affair northern ireland select committee
this morning he's expected
to face questions of the implementation
of the northern ireland
protocol that's coming up in just a
second or two tomorrow
is here what are we expecting tomorrow
well we're expecting kay that lord frost
will get questions from mps about
exactly what he's going to do
to resolve a standoff between the uk and
the european union
as regards what happens in northern
ireland
we know that since a protocol an
agreement was made between the uk
and the european union back in december
when we left
on exactly how trade would work because
of course
to avoid a hard border checked between
northern ireland
and the republic of ireland what boris
johnson chose to do
was instead to have those checks on
trade between
the rest of the uk and northern ireland
so far enforcing that has been very
difficult
and a number of grace periods have had
to be introduced i think we're going to
see lord frost
talking to mps now
i'm involved in a legal action against
the protocol for commercial equities
thank you so lord frost you you you
heard that so that's
that's under advisement as as as it were
good
um minister let me let me ask let me
start if i may just by
establishing a few sort of basic uh
fact questions because i think that
there is some uncertainty
uh in the media and in the world of
politics
um and hopefully this might just be a
sort of quick fire
yes or no round to to to get us into
second gear
could you confirm that her majesty's
government
negotiated with the european union
the northern ireland protocol
well thank you chairman good morning
before i answer that question i'd just
like to
um make one remark um up front
it's pleasure to hear today i just want
to to be clear first of all that my
primary responsibility in this new
ministerial role is to the
uh the european scrutiny committee and
the europe affairs committee and the
lords for
for my role and obviously the treaties
do cover a wide range of other
issues um and those are primarily for
other departments to take forward
um with their committees as regards
scrutiny
so i say that by way of preamble to to
make clear that i
appear before you uh this morning as a
as a courtesy
um i'm very happy to do so um but it
obviously isn't a
a precedent for uh my general
appearances before this committee and
obviously the secretary of state for
northern ireland is the the primary um
interlocutor
um i apologize also for the fact that we
we
only have 90 minutes uh today i'm afraid
i've got a pressing
uh commitment at 11. um
but we're very happy to be here i am my
my co-witness mark davis
um okay but let's uh as we are
understand first of all can i just say
i'm i'm
sort of disappointed to hear that um
caveat about attendance um but we'll we
will look at that um
offline as they say so turning back to
the questions could you just confirm
that her majesty's government
uh with the with the cdl as lead
negotiated with the european
union the northern ireland protocol
so um actually in 2019 it
was uh i uh working to the prime
minister who negotiated the the protocol
uh cdl in 2020 negotiated
the uh the provisions that eventually
surfaced as decisions of the joint
committee
at the end of 2020 and cdl was in the
lead in that process
while i was negotiating tca okay thank
you
um i presume that we are correct
to assume that her majesty's government
understood the protocol
what it had negotiated and signed up to
indeed we had a very clear understanding
of
what the intention behind the the
protocol was
and um as you will be very well aware
german um
it's a very delicately balanced set of
provisions
um with quite a lot of loose ends
and open-ended provisions for subsequent
negotiation
and the spirit of good faith
that's so necessary to uh make the
protocol work
uh was prevalent in 2019 and we
we hope uh uh that it can continue to be
as we find ways of operating it okay
and and when the um when mr grove was
chance with russia's lancaster concluded
the negotiations in that flurry of
activity
in early december um
you as the prime minister's right
right-hand man
sherpa lead negotiator um the person in
whom
uh all the trust was vested use you
effect you signed off
the document which we now refer to as
the northern ireland protocol
so um the the protocol was agreed
and uh in 2019
and obviously um came into force in part
in january 2020
and uh the rest of it at the end of uh
the year 2020. the the joint committee
decisions
which which sort of expand and interpret
it um
uh as as i said uh cdl was
responsible for negotiating but of
course we're all part of
one team trying to get the best deal for
the uk as we ran into the end of 2020.
um so no but so nobody was blindsided on
any of this
well i i think we exchange information
within government
uh pretty well about what's what's going
on so we all had a good understanding of
the uh the decisions we all had a good
understanding of the things we
we wanted to negotiate uh in both
frameworks
and um for whatever reason had been
unable to
thank you could you could you just tell
the committee what
um what assessment you make
has a senior minister member of the
cabinet
um and who is confidant of the prime
minister
with regards to the importance of
political trust
and business confidence
um in the robustness and reliability of
a regulatory
regime are both now and moving forward
well i think um i could expand on that
question for for some time because it's
quite
a significant sort of thing it's not
quite
it's not quite a phd question but i
won't do so
um you know obviously stability and
predictability
in a um a regulatory framework
is an important element in in business
confidence
i think the difficulty that we've had uh
since the start of the year
is that there or at least since the end
of january is that there's been very
visible um uh weakening of consent
uh in one community in northern ireland
for the arrangements in the protocol and
that's
obviously produced kind of instability
and uncertainty about
um i'm going to come on to that issue um
in a moment um let me just ask about the
business confidence please
we have heard as i know you know and the
chancellor the doctor of lancaster knows
we as a committee have heard throughout
this process
and i sort of summarize effectively the
message of business whether it's
business in ni
or business in gb um
and it in turns it runs like this we
don't really care what the rules and
regulations
are as long as they're clear deliverable
and we know the phrase and we know that
those rules are going to be there for a
period of time
if there's instability and chopping and
changing and uncertainty
don't expect us to invest personnel
resource
and financial resource in getting used
to them and putting in place processes
processes or their implementation if
they're likely to change in short order
can you confirm that you understand the
importance of that
stability and confidence requirement of
business
on both sides of the irc i think
everything we've done has been trying to
build stability and confidence in
amongst business
and um i agree with you that um
you know they look at the current
situation with
um you know with some with some
nervousness
um i think they also look at the
the way the protocol is operating and
the impact is having on their
supply chains and ability to deliver for
consumers and that's also an issue of
concern for them that has
come out of the consultations i've had
do you think that um the perpetual
um bubbling threat
of triggering of the uk government
triggering article 16
um assists or otherwise
that confidence and trust process
so i think that uh i mean
all options remain on the table as
regards with the step four
steps forwards and um obviously we'd
prefer to find
negotiated ways forwards if we can
um if that's not possible obviously you
know other options remain
uh on the table as pm said over the
weekend but
i think there i mean this is a sort of
intellectual debate really i think there
comes a point where
the unsatisfactoriness of the current
situation and the attempts to operate it
you know in itself in itself
contributes to the um uncertainty and
instability and then
a responsible effort to bring
stability and certainty can improve the
situation
rather than than make it more difficult
so obviously if we
if we judge that's the um the situation
then we we look at the range of options
that might
uh uh bring further stability
do you do you hear the sort of um
the tearing out of hair the the the
throwing the
throwing the book through the window
moment from some at that answer
where you refer to the
unsatisfactoriness uh effectively you
say there are elements of the protocol
which are unsatisfactory
but this is a protocol that the
government negotiated and signed up to
so there are um the the difficulty
is the way that the protocol is being
operated is not in our view
consistent with the um
the intentions of us as negotiators and
to take one one point to illustrate in a
concrete way
it is simply not enough for um
for people to point to the provision in
the protocol
which says that the union customs code
should apply because there's
also a provision of the protocol article
6 2 which says that everybody
both sides should do their best to
minimize checks and controls
uh in the ports of of northern ireland
so obviously that provision
cannot be um read straight
and it's a matter of judgment as to
whether both sides are exercising the
responsibility under
under article 6 2. so it is not a
a simple black and white question the
way of implementing it
you mentioned the word negotiator there
or negotiation
um i don't want to ask you another
doctoral thesis question
but uh if you if you were filling out
the form which said
david what are your what are your
strongest
um uh qualities as it were or skills
do you see yourself principally as a
negotiator
or do you see yourself now as an
implementer and i'm not trying to engage
in linguistic semantics because you'll
know in a political sense there are two
very different those are two very
different things
well i think it's both to be honest i
mean obviously i've got some broader
responsibilities than purely um
looking at the northern ireland protocol
but i think
you know what we are trying to do is
operate a system
in a way that is consistent with the
purpose of the system and the overriding
political um uh situation in northern
ireland and the
belfast go friday agreement and um
you know that that involves um
uh finding and negotiating ways
to um to make these arrangements work in
a satisfactory way and we we haven't
found that yet
that is that's obvious i think looking
at the situation in northern ireland so
is going to take discussions and
negotiations to to improve it
and are those discussions um timely
at speed and well resourced or their
sort of
post-lunch sunday afternoons trial
so there are um discussions going on the
whole time
um i think i've been very few days in
the last
month or two where there haven't been
technical discussions of some kind
or another with my team or with so
lord frost answering her questions
saying that he sees himself
as a negotiator and an enforcer
when it comes to the northern ireland
protocol
in another life i'm going to show people
how to frame up for zoom chats
coming up how much damage has the
scandal around the
diana interview done to the bbc we'll
hear the thoughts of the former bbc
governor
sir richard air next
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
they have breached the road there is a
lot of
gas being fired all around us
it is an absolute carnival kind of
atmosphere out here for prime minister
modi's decisive victory
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
[Applause]
the roads have been inundated the only
way out
is to get people by boat
what is shared that over 200 people
might have died because of these
landslides
this on any given day would have been
bustling with people but today
it's absolutely deserted
this is one of the most sensitive areas
of of northeast delhi where there's been
clashes
i'm never lazarus and i'm skies reporter
based in delhi
or like we say in my language is relay
i am tauntive the founder and the ceo of
the news in africa this picture changed
my whole career
and my whole life my mission is simple
to bring back power to africa
and our aim is to turn the dark
continent that i saw in 2008
into a brighter and prosperous one by
2014
now the former director-general of the
bbc has admitted that he was wrong
not to sack martin beshear of the way he
secured an interview with diana princess
of wales
tony hall cleared martin beshear after
he admitted using forging bank
statements to
persuade the princess to speak i spoke
to the former bbc governor sir richard
eyre earlier and he said he felt the
explanations from the bbc bosses were
plausible
my explanation
of the whole uh fiasco
was that the people involved were
consumed
by contagious ambition
blind ambition uh john burt had come
into the bbc as director general the
third in the line the previous two
had been fired by the the chairman
mahmoud new casi
he came in with a specific uh
program of putting news
on the front foot he thought that the
bbc news gathering
and news reporting of the time was very
very
complacent and inward looking so he inc
he was encouraging uh the the
the news department to go on the front
foot
now panorama like a number of bbc
programs is very self-contained or was
very self-contained it probably still is
semi-autonomous so there was this group
who got this
massive scoop i don't think anybody
or maybe the panorama people were but
certainly not
john bert and tony hall were terribly
interested in how
bashir had got access to princess diana
the whole thing was
very much conducted in in secrecy
everybody outside that inner circle was
astonished that
last year this totally unknown reporter
had got the interview and our questions
were answered
were asked but but none were answered so
i i think that the program
the film panorama was filmed
people say well he forced his way into
dinah i don't think that's true at all
because i think diana was absolutely
delighted
to meet an unknown reporter who wasn't
robin day or some other uh heavyweight
who she could manipulate and if you
remember she was keen to reply
to a very sycophantic documentary a bbc
style documentary
that itv had made the year before which
was
a reporter jonathan
will be interviewing prince charles and
she was infuriated by that
she saw this guy who seemed absolutely
charming
and intelligent and totally sympathetic
it was filmed in secret
it was edited in secret not even the
board of management knew
that it was happening until the film had
been made
campaigners are calling on the
government to honor a 2019 election and
pledge to double dementia
research funding more than 50 000 people
have signed a petition
saying dementia is now the biggest
long-term challenge that we face earlier
i spoke to the actor
stephen thompkinson who told me about
losing his dad brian to the illness in
2015
and why he signed the petition dad uh
suffered for seven years with dementia
and it's a very
long and very painful process where
you just lose more of them every day
you're left with uh the sort of outside
shell
and the person that you knew has been
taken
from you it's incredibly painful um
but as soon as dad had eventually passed
away
i i didn't want anyone else to suffer in
the same way so i
i contacted alzheimer's research uk to
see if there was
anything that i could do to help their
cause and i've been involved with them
ever since
government promised at the last election
i think in brighton's saying to double
its investment
into dementia research to more than 160
million pounds a year
um doesn't look as though they've
fulfilled that as of yet
um as a campaigner how does that make
very angry um you know
i'm sure this government won't be the
first government to make
election promises that they they don't
deliver on but this is
two years down the line they were trying
to secure votes of that they
they got those votes uh they promised
that they would double the research to
160 million
pounds a year which sounds an awful lot
but at the moment there is
no nothing to prevent alzheimer's
there's nothing to cure it and it's
costing our economy 26 billion
pounds a year so we're not asking
for we're just asking them to honor
their promise
you know it's it's a very basic thing
having raced the most powerful petrol
cars in the world former
f1 champion nico rosberg is trying to
turn the wall green
he's leading the green tech festival
which promotes high-tech solutions for
combating climate change earlier he told
me all about the festival
and the changes he and his family are
making to reduce their impact
on the environment first of all also the
latest scientific facts
that have arisen which are the most
alarming we're going to be presenting
those discussing those
and then it's all about creating
partnerships and showcasing
the technologies that are really going
to help us most
in this fight against climate change um
and how have you
changed your life would you say um nico
in order to become more climate
conscious to become more green
yeah so as a as i'm making a very
conscious uh
effort myself um in my daily life first
of all with my family at home so no more
plastic at home
or reducing driving an electric car and
also in my businesses that we're always
going climate neutral in all our
businesses we
we use a software to really analyze our
co2 emissions
um so it's really about making an effort
and of course i'm not perfect and we're
not perfect
but i think if everybody makes an effort
and does his part then
then we really have uh we can hope that
we can achieve those
ambitious targets that we all need to
get to
find out what's happening as far as the
weather is concerned now here's nas
hey nice good morning good morning it's
going to be fine warm and sunny for most
places some will be cloudy though
hot and humid in the southeast highest
temperature of the year so far likely
there before thunderstorms
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning lots of fine warm
conditions out there for today
particularly across parts of the
southeast in fact there it's
going to be hot and humid and we're
likely to see the highest temperature of
the year so far beating only monday's
high which was 29.7 degrees celsius in
teddington
but into tonight there will be some
torrential downpours with
thunderstorms on their way and for some
today it's going to be a cloudy one for
this afternoon we'll see brighter skies
develop around eastern parts of ireland
and northern ireland but for southern
scotland it stays
cloudy with patchy light rain and
drizzle the same two across the
northwest of england the west
wales down towards cornwall as well the
rest of england and wales
very warm locally hot in the south east
lots of sunshine sunny spurs for island
northern ireland and the rest of
scotland too but some scattered showers
across the windy northwest
then tonight there will be heavy rains
torrential downpours moving northwards
over england and wells
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well that's it from us for today we've
been talking to
liz trust today about the deal that's
been done between the united kingdom
and australia lots of uk farmers not at
all happy about that she says we need to
look forward
and it will be better for both countries
in the long run
she also talked to us about what should
happen with
care workers and whether or not it
should be mandatory
that they are double jabbed if they work
in care homes you can find out what she
said about that on my twitter feed
at k burley uh coming up in just a few
moments time
it is ian king live of course and then
we are back at
seven o'clock in the morning will you
join us then
it would be my pleasure if you did see
you then
[Music]
we are at a breaking point and we need
to work
now and fast even though young people
are vulnerable to the import of climate
change
young people can also become the change
agents that we need to address
the climate impact in my campaign or in
advocacy work i work entirely with young
people
so that their voices can be heard so
they can also influence
decision making from the local level to
the national level and thankfully
we are making progress in our regard
you